[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah yeah what's going on what's going
on lords of the realm
what's going on what's going on we're
gonna fire up some getting other
people in the room making sure the mic
check is good smitty smith what's up
dan rodriguez what's going on oh we got
hustle in the building
meds in the building what's going on
what i'm saying let me know if my levels
is good deployed what's going on
how y'all doing trying to get everybody
in the room
in the front you know there's a lot of a
lot of section in the front of the
congregation so get to the front y'all
let me know if my level is good
all right smitty my man that's what i'm
talking about i see the horns
thank you sir thank you sir yeah your
co-host man should be coming in soon
i'm just uh getting people rocking and
then of course i think the legendary
timmy
will join us in progress king will be
here any minute to give us that
copyright strike so i'm a new child
y'all know how he do
and i don't know where addicts at so
hopefully we'll get the
difficult getting conquering here at
some point
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right mike check mic check chat
what's going on we are
waiting for a addict we didn't know
what's going on we start with adam
i need y'all to speak to the people lord
ghost real quick might check my check
mike check what up you already know lord
ainsley might check my check
what's going on you already know and the
king
might check my
all right let me know everybody i can
hear them i think i think we good we
might have to start what up
what's up megatron what's going on we're
going to probably start without the
attic i don't know
yet but we'll get it in a few minutes
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
all right and we are live
welcome to the ireland podcast the lords
of gaming.net
episode number 167 it's another glorious
sunday we're back at the round table on
the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special
guests and we've got the xbox game
showcase prediction show
and ghost of sushima impressions to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
i want to introduce two lords who are
not only solid friends to the realm but
in my opinion
both represent the informative and
analytical aspects
of what's good in gaming introducing
first
the creating host of the xbox expansion
pass the full-time teacher by day
and leader of the xbox cool kids by
night
live from north carolina and making his
return
into the realm of the lords my man
lord it's separate ghost how you doing
sir dude i've been looking forward to
that intro
all week they're always fire thank you
for having me i'm so excited to be here
what a
week man i'm so pumped i'm hyped
good to have you back brother real
quickly what have you been playing sir
oh man i recently wrapped last of us two
yeah
i've been playing let's see what happen
oh the new rocket arena game
that ea came out with kind of stealth
launch real weird real weird
uh approach that but but interesting
game to say the least and then
man halo wars 2 is my go-to it's been a
good time getting that atriox in that's
what's up brother get ready
no doubt we're gonna get into it and
introducing second
the creating host of the big cast
podcast and the head of the
esteemedseasongaming.com my nhl is
streets of rage
brethren and also a king of the statues
alumni
live from kansas city and also
making his return into the realm of the
lords my
lord aislie about it how we doing sir
what is happening guys man
nobody does an intro like them doesn't
look normal
it's too good it's ridiculous
yeah yeah we even tried with two people
and we still couldn't top it
no you know i just thought that day they
killed me
y'all killed it yeah
it was like they did the kid and played
it was getting out every day
i was like if they did not practice that
and they just
rip off of that i said they're out of
control actually we didn't practice that
either
i think we got lucky we got lucky i
killed him i was i was
very humble very happy but anyway man no
super excited to be here can't wait to
talk some xbox talk some toshiba
let's get to it you already know man and
you already know we got the well we
don't have four horsemen we have three
three husband of gaming addicts still in
the bushes i don't know where he is
hopefully we can get him ready for the
show
but of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
and also the sastradamus mr offline
profile illuminati and lord patron of
the iron bank my man
lord sovereign how are we doing sir
doing well what's going on fellas
chilling i'm doing very well yeah i'm
ready i'm ready i'm ready
sir oh they are well hold on excuse me
hold on let me
get back to that guys stream kingdom
with the 5
super chat have a great show guys can't
wait to listen when i get home i'll be
soaking in
an epsom salt bath tonight laughing at
the knees in the foot
did i miss something no i didn't miss
anything now you're good you're good so
what's been going on have you been
playing leah
is it cherry blossom season what's good
cherry blossom season yeah to the point
that i i
haven't even turned on paper mario yet
i've been in there
um yeah so i'm obviously gonna have more
to say about it but i've been playing it
um i have some things to say some things
that i love about it some things that
are
just so so about it but overall the
experience is
nice i've enjoyed it so that's what's up
so it's been that primarily anything
else
pretty much that yeah that's it that
that's pretty much it i got past last of
us last week and it was just like it
took a little
like a week to decompress and from there
right
yeah shout out to you king i i listen to
that he like
yeah i listen i listened to the second
spoiler cast you were on and i wish i
had been
back from work to because you guys
really broke down like every character
and sort of what they mean to the
overall arc of the game because i think
it's important i think
they don't feel so bad really i did yeah
i definitely wanted to be there because
the thing is
in a game like that you don't introduce
characters
to to just have them not mean anything
to the overarching story right
you need them there for that reason so
it was a very interesting listen it was
fantastic
yeah i did not know thank you so much i
did not know that we was going to go 2
hours and 45 minutes oh but that's
always the case that's always the case
though
and we have speeded up at the end and
cut out a couple of scenes
that i thought needed a lot of
conversation too
but when i saw and i'm always going to
say this to me
the the genius of neil druckmann when
you
look at the art of the 3d modeling of
the characters
broke them down into four different
sections every main character has
four different skins what he had in that
in thinking in my opinion because i'm
not in neil druckmann's uh
wonderful mind but um what i've noticed
is that
he they had different motivations at
different stages of their life
you know every single skin is
significant because it sort of
exemplifies the moment that they're in
in their life and their journey like
especially like when i saw i saw abby's
final skin
boy for anything so what the hell
like what what happened yes but you knew
at that point in time
you know where she was and what it was
about
you know and it was tell it was told
through
the art it was told through the sound of
the game
and it was told through the story if if
you
skip if you're one of those people to
skip those little notes that was around
the board
that sound like addict
and much like those any other game the
attic does that in you he comes
his opinion doesn't have the context
that someone else's opinion would have
if they really
if they really explore in the game i
really know
but then his argument would be like but
i don't this person's motivation doesn't
make sense
it's a lot of those little stories that
they link and then you get to a body
that was trying to save his wife to
realize he did not
make it and he was just hoping that they
did it's just
it was a lot i really loved every aspect
if you remember the story of
ish from the first game they take that
to another level with this like
they do the same thing and it makes you
feel attached to the world in a way that
other games don't
do necessarily that's what's right
that's what's up shout out to dave
rodriguez from season gaming
i've hacked the season gaming super chat
account and i'm transferring all the
mariano pompa's donation to the lords
this week
got regulator with two dollars super
chat good morning lords one word
velocity we got we got jd gabriel
find out super chat let's start the show
off right i expect some needs to be on
the line
and i have some collection from p rock
if gold goes free
have a great show iop whoa i guess
you're gonna go get those collections
and we have mariano pompa yeah quotation
marks we'll see
dan how dare you little seasoned gaming
coo
going on all right
so that's been this song pretty much
yeah that's it is that hurry no and
of course we have the incredible hulk of
this aka
the access gamer the lord of combat
sports
king of the statues who demands nothing
less than that premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
oh beloved lord king how are we doing
sir
yo so uh yeah it was no kos this week
wasn't really feeling up to it every
time i went to start to talk about miles
morale didn't remember
my one your guys voted on her man he's
here um every time i went to talk about
him
um and it wasn't that i didn't have
enthusia uh enthusiasm
for the character it was just more that
um
i just had to feel where i was gonna
come from because he means so much
and it's like uh it's like a creative
character that made it
you know so it's it's the thing with
that but um this week
wow oh please guys if y'all got a chance
to check me out uh yesterday on dolph
lex uh go uh subscribe to this channel
fantastic
statue podcast you know we were having
such a
uh crazy time with the kraken hunters
this is out of control um but this week
i was playing
a wonderful roguelike game that's in
game pass shout out the game feather
boy back to the building
you know they drop ghosts of sashima and
uh we dropped neon
abyss
listen i know i know it sounds like ah
man
it can't hang with that yes it can sir
um full full full disclosure
that game once you start it it's
very hard to yank yourself away
my son started the forward joe i looked
in on that and i was like you know how
is that
and you know he says it's pretty good so
i downloaded it and
um well he downloaded neon abyss when i
did right
and i started playing this game that
game is like what's that other um
it's like dead cells okay but it's like
dead cells in a way
that is a shooter now where dead cells
is in the way
like you know like kind of like a
shooter more like a ninja
he's like neon is amazing he said his is
fire
absolutely insane it got to the point
yesterday i was doing so much
that um i started screen capturing like
because when you die
all your little things that you do you
get a cold like back in the days
i was screen capturing my code and
posting it to dudes that was having a
tough time
in the game um they can lead off where
you was at oh that's fire okay so you
can share your codes with other people
in the world and they can play
kind of like your experiences your
dungeons because every engine changes
um all the artifacts and stuff like that
changes
and you get to collect them it is
probably one of the most addicting
roguelike type games that i have been
playing in a
wow so i thought um shout out to
christopher hart for paying the sixteen
dollars for it
we gonna shave up without being gay fast
as we do it bro he keeping
me sideways i was like i'm playing me on
a [ __ ] he said yeah i purchased that
then he was
i said yeah but i got it for free he
said but i own mine
okay if you felt that that felt
warranted
knock yourself out but um we're doing
the same exact thing but
you personally think you own something
if they take it off you brought it
digitally brother
oh no they got me again
shout out to game pass so so um i was
playing cross code somebody
uh told you to check out cross code yes
this game pass it's because
you don't know winning on drop stuff
like they take out three games
dropping 10. like i don't know what
breakthrough
is but that's not a good ratio right
you're right
like we're gonna take away three but
we're gonna give you ten like what
thank you getting past that's crazy
small caliber i'm trying to get some
challenges in that and i was doing the
messenger
nice at the same time um i just made it
up to the 16-bit part
okay ghost ghosts know about that right
now
that's right that's right i just had the
developer on the xbox expansion pass
that's a good deal man very cool dude
fieri theory
amazing amazing game when you go from
the 8-bit graphics to the 16-back
you actually see the difference um and
the fact that you can jump through
realms
oh you know king have you have you
played much in 16
you said you just got there have you
played it yet no i played some
you know okay but then abyss came in and
put the boot on the neck
i got that new game feels like driving a
new car you want to go to 60. i won't go
six then i'm gonna go 200.
i want to take it to the window i will
tell you this
messenger 16-bit once you hit there you
finish the first game you're now playing
the second game the second game is in
metroidvania the first one's ninja
gaiden
you're playing a completely different
game and that's a hard it's a jarring
transition once you
realize what you got to do but once
you're in the zone you're playing the
sequel basically it's crazy
yeah that's about it um yeah so shout
out to
another week of uh getting up hitting
that track
jogging yeah i know about that yeah i
tried now
shout out to being saw this week salute
to that yo shout out to uh stitch 6669
two dollar super chat
king there's a special on storage units
two for one
i guess for these oh yeah man they know
they're easy
oh everybody put those crests up oh put
the crescent midway monster
monster
i heard the horse too yo that's from the
shot midway you [ __ ] shot
that sound like some shot talk right
midway um make sure you go check the
exclusive video of me getting this
ah tattoo on my channel guys
it's the only way you want to get a
nipple bruh
yo salute man to the rub did we all
caught up everything else
yeah we're all good yes sir and of
course we have the gaming ninja himself
the shinobi lord cognito spreading that
running to the run with iop
not telling you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear will be says
how's that chest feeling today
yo will be the savage
that's right i knew that's some shot
town talk i like it that's what's up man
but yeah but for me like i said just
been on
playing you know it's cherry blossom
season y'all y'all know what it is you
know what i'm doing
that's what i've been waiting for y'all
see my twitter timeline y'all know the
vibes
i already know i already know we're
gonna get to it but yeah it's been that
and then obviously uh shout out to
ebantus
and zoey on the last word she came
through one of the best destiny players
i'll put that on my to watch list today
oh man she's fantastic she's she two
men's raids
like what yes she's a beast and like
gambit like she's one of the top in the
world like she's just telling us the
stories
as a female gamer how like dudes be
underestimated and then she come through
with smoke
like it's bad yeah check that out it was
a fun fun show we had a lot of fun with
that and um yeah man that's it
so um soft uh i don't know if you got
the the little
message behind the scene if we want to
come up with something during show on
your own or you didn't get anything
i have not gotten anything okay okay so
what i'll do
you have to check yours because he's
sending it to you yeah i'm gonna just
check because we got some things we
might want to
do okay okay cool cool cool yes yes yes
so please
um if you can send that this off so if
you still don't get it just uh message
me i'll send it to you and we'll take
care of that
and then yeah um let's get into the poll
last week last week's poll results are
in the people have spoken
to the question with phil spencer's
latest statement regarding the series x
being held back do you agree that games
should not be locked into having to buy
a new device
in order to experience it the winner of
our three-way ilp
poll at 62 was
yes the majority of games scaled for pc
already group coming in at second place
at 20
of the vote was no game design will
always be held back by the lowest common
denominator
and in last place and only 17 of the
vote was i don't care
both playstation 5 and siriusx's damn
controller for pc
so shout out to all the lords let's get
ainsley on this man
i never got a chance to talk to you
brother in reference to
what side of the fence you are in
reference to that so
people have spoken what does ageley
think about this whole oh man
this is yeah this is this is one of
those dumb debates i don't know
i uh all right so
i was talking to someone about this the
other day they actually got in my dms
and they were like
because we talked about it on big cast
and i was we were making the point that
it's a dumb argument to phil's point
right this is nothing more than a meme
that people like to argue about
um so there there's a whole bunch of
other things we could get into of the
why this whole debate of game design is
held back by the lowest common
denominator but
the reason they're talking about 12 and
24 months right
going into the next generation is
because the console itself
is not the only thing that factors into
game development
you've got a whole and you know this as
well as i do there's a whole bunch of
other things that have to mature
from the tool sets to the middleware to
the apis
to you know developer knowledge game
engines like they talked about unreal
fives not even going to be fully
available until late 2021 correct
um all these things have to mature in
the generation
so when you're talking about game design
being held back as if
right now or starting in 2819 they
started designing for this ultimate
pinnacle
series x or ps5 for reaching somehow
gain that's not how game development
works
it's just not so
matter if you're just speaking matter of
fact no i don't think anything's being
held back i think people trying to tell
phil spencer he's wrong sound like
idiots
and um i mean i mean how arrogant do you
have to be to sit on twitter
work in your job wherever and tell
phil spencer who's been in this for 25
plus years he's one of the 16 top people
at the biggest company in the world
and you're going to tell him he doesn't
know what he's talking about
what are you even doing like are you
saying there's a bunch of armchair
developers are you implying
development going you can look how red i
am
it's tight it just doesn't make any
sense
like stop with the [ __ ] listen to
the man
those are the same people that tell
everybody that their their oxygen levels
are low from wearing
yeah oh my god
there's so many things that people don't
understand about
myself included right i'm no expert but
there's so many things that go into game
developments
besides now the ps5 is out so you
develop for the ps5 that's not how it
works man there's
a million things that go into game
development that takes time to mature
that's why you see the pinnacle of games
come
late in the generation versus early in
the generation let me actually a
question aims
um yeah you know we saw the controller
um and
the demo that was there is the
playstation
4 holding back to five because that
looked like playstation
4.
[Laughter]
i got no i got nothing away from that
one stay away from me
some tablets we are going to address and
um yeah
so how it goes off when the when the big
ghost came
to live out the name
yeah we had some liquid swords dropped
this week man
so we're gonna get it too we know what
we're here for but we gotta talk about
this
big big release on playstation
the ghost of sushima has released so i
just want to get everyone's impressions
really quick for those who have played
obviously as i know you have but i
haven't spoke to our ghost here on the
panel
i didn't know if he got it he picked it
up what's going on
man i won't take too much of your time
on this but i will tell you this
the the the gaming gods saw me
on not having fun with the last of us
too which is a masterpiece that's not
fun
they saw that and then they conspired
against me man i tried to buy this thing
three different ways on my psn my psn
wouldn't take it my credit card wouldn't
go
up it was so frustrating
and it was i was mad so real talk i have
not played it yet
it looks it looks like a more fun
game than last of us too and i hear
people talking
talking like it is they're saying it's
not as high quality in some ways i'm so
excited for the conversations around
these two games
what a great way for playstation to end
their generation uh props to everybody
enjoying it
you have to go buy it from the store
physically or um
finally did the credit card and
everything stuff finally go through
as far as i can tell it's still loading
king i can't tell them
all right so you got it to start it's
loading it usually it takes a day
station
it takes seven to twelve hours for it
that thing to load
one and god forbid it's like
or we'll call a dude if you're
downloading call of duty you might as
well throw your
console in the bushes
what's up with that paypal that's what i
use i use paypal
on their network that's a good call
now yeah
[Laughter]
and of course i gotta go right into
ainsley man i see i saw the screen shots
you know i had to throw the cherry
blossoms on top of that right
i see quick black and white now what are
we doing hazel we doing japanese voice
you know what i'm saying yeah of course
you gotta go japanese voice man you got
to let's go
that was the first thing i switched when
i turned the game on um
yeah man i'm liking it uh the luke's
point this is a very different game
from last of us too so to get them like
you know less than a month apart
is uh is kind of surreal um i don't know
man i'm enjoying it i
i know some people are really really
hyped up on it and you know talking game
of the year talk and all this i'm not
quite there
um you know i'm not that high
no no no
it's a game i'm having fun with you know
and i'm one of those where like uh you
know you got the cinematics
and you get on the story path and i'm
like just finish this because i want to
go wander off
you know what i mean and i just i've
spent six seven hours i think playing it
since friday and i haven't done a single
main mission yet
same thing it's funny you said that yeah
i just like exploring so
it you know the world's really cool
there's lots of things to find the
combat's fun
uh i got no complaints about it per se
other than the camera pisses me off
mm-hmm um it's just it's frustrating um
at least give me the option to lock on
to it
yeah i don't know i agree with that i
agree they definitely give me the option
speaking of options you're playing on a
pro
why because no
you don't have the option between high
resolution mode and frame rate
and what i also notice is when you put
it on frame rate it does absolutely
nothing
it doesn't change so it's it's 30 right
and then it's 30. so well so frame rate
locks to 30.
it locks to 30 yeah right yeah and
that's it and it brings it down to like
whatever whatever you or something like
that
okay yeah resolution to probably 1080p
because you know that i don't think
so right now
other games that have that pro uh
feature actually
it's a lock 60. you know they do i i
just found it weird
any uh the photo mode's incredible right
we're just talking about that um so you
can make all kinds of crazy photos which
is cool but the um
one other thing that annoys me i don't
know some of the things with the engine
like um it feels
um it feels similar to days gone some of
the complaints i had with that with the
way like the the physics of like your
character in the environment don't
always work so well
yeah like you can't go off ledges
smoothly or like you go to walk across a
bridge and he just kind of stands there
and does that like you know
3d shuffle so you don't expect to see
those types of things out of a big
budget
you know aaa sony game they're there
um but no the game's the game's really
good i'm enjoying it um
i will say it's one of those games where
like you know i told you
before we got started i just stopped
playing it and i'm thinking about
playing it so it's got something right
what's up that's a good sign that's a
good sign that's a good sign i agree all
right
let's get a stitch with the 10 hour
super chat question for the panel now
that bungie has
a marketing deal with xbox is that
confirmed i don't even know that yeah
do you think the reason the next
generation expansion got pushed back is
to debut the game at 60 fps on console
yes sir i will say it's definitely
debuting at 60 um
i don't know about the timing that is
interesting about the time i believe uh
beyond light is november 20th so i it
does line up i don't know
we shall see you stitch hey big head put
that back a little bit
real nice lately i won't say that so um
yeah let's get to it uh
lord sovereign what are we feeling about
when the big ghost came to live out the
deal
[Laughter]
so um i'm enjoying it i'm enjoying it um
but there are things like i think
ainsley touched on every single point
that i
i completely like the camera
the camera feels like it's way too close
for an open world game like yes
the field of view usually just a little
bit pulled back out a little bit more so
you can see more of the world
especially when riding the horse right
like it's like on you
but like yeah and i noticed that from
early screenshots i'm like why are they
so close i mean i like that
i like the fact because you get to see
you know all the work that got put into
the character model and
what um yeah for an open world game it's
a little just it feels
it's a little disconcerting to be up on
top the character like that
so that again with the climbing
mechanics as well like
his climb and his jumping off of stuff
is like the most disgusting i've ever
seen
i guess it's bad it's bad but again
um where where the game really shines to
me
is just the world and the atmosphere um
they they nailed feudal japan in a way
no game has never really known
or no game has ever really attempted and
i'm gonna say this right now
this coming gen we do get the assassin's
creed field of japan game that we've
been asking for forever
watch it's coming it's coming see that's
what i was talking about
yeah so um beyond that um the combat is
fantastic in the beginning
and you you're almost fooled into
thinking it's somewhat simplistic
it's not i mean all the different uh
skill trees
uh once you start opening up like the
the the ghost sort of skill tree
and and and using sort of uh you know
whatever
uh uh dishonorable tactics
it really opens up the the gameplay and
the combat in a way that
an open world game oftentimes kind of
dumbs down a little bit just because
in in the service of exploring this huge
world and all the other mechanics
involved in that
sometimes i get stunned down a little
bit this is the focus of this game like
it really
is that that that sensation of of being
a samurai
like taking someone head on or deciding
to take someone on like when you call
out and you do the
this game seeps that that that that
classic sort of kurosawa
uh uh samurai like love that we grew up
with right
so what else what else um so i'm
enjoying the game from a gameplay
standpoint
um i don't think everything that i see
in the open world like initially
i from early things that i heard people
playing the game earlier were talking
about um
well the the side missions are really
like witcher-esque in terms of their
variety and stuff like that
and so far i haven't seen that
necessarily
i don't want to say that stuff yeah okay
this is good it just it's not that it
it's definitely not that
so it does sort of feel like it still
falls into those those sort of tropes
that that you expect from these open
world games sort of repetitive stuff
and to sort of uh level up your
character um but again i think
what saves the game for me really is
this atmosphere that they really is just
bathing in this atmosphere that
separates from any other
environment oh yeah it really does so a
little disappointed in that it doesn't
feel like it's moving
the open world genre forward in a way
that i feel like
other sony first party have done with
with like the the single-player
narrative game i think
you got awarded interesting things
obviously last of us did interesting
things with narrative
and if you look at the open world stuff
on playstation you look at horizon
i don't really think horizon moved it
forward in terms of what these these
open world games do
um obviously story setting is is
something we hadn't seen before and the
same goes
is true for this um but beyond that i'm
enjoying the game
again uh the combat i know is going to
get even better
um yeah so i'm enjoying it i don't know
all this story is about it's better than
the witcher 3 and it's better than oh
wow
this is coming
[Applause]
it's objectively not true like that's
true
you can have the argument about graphics
but it's a five-year-old game comparing
it to a 2020 game okay so graphics okay
combat yes debate the combat in this
game is considerably more robust than
what you get in the witcher
um beyond and we're done damn right
no no honestly and we're done
like that the conversation guys man
and then again and then again addict's
not hitting the defenders
on twitter talking about the stories
better and uh
and i'm like bro like no because
i'm getting
heroic character that's fighting against
the tide and he loves that and he loves
it
big boss fights big boss
when he was talking about the intro to
the game like oh my god i've never seen
an intro like this
i'm like you've seen this in every
blockbuster movie you've ever seen this
is the intro
right and i'm not knocking it for that
but it is it
it is that you know i mean it's not
shredding new ground there like
you know what i mean oh my god
you already know that like you said in
your name is the you know shinobi
are you trying to say
right now you are sipping the sake
right now and i'm going to destroy this
game on a level
here we go well let's see if saab is
finished with his landing
you know i'm done with my standard
i'm enjoying the game they they really
hit it out of the park when it came to
atmosphere and getting that that sense
of feudal japan they
they knocked it out of the park oh one
other little gripe i have
right here it makes itself super like
for an open world game you need to have
levity like if you look at the last of
us and it has levity
a game like this has to have a little
bit of levity like it takes itself super
serious seriously
yeah fair enough shout out to uh what's
it to scrub nurse downloading the game
if i have as much fun as afro samurai i
mean
let's go you already know salute salute
man
so oh hold on cat daddy hold on
better than witcher 3 grab the chin
kleptos
for sure i'll feel you man it's a kick
man i i saw you
downloaded you had a little video going
up about your supporting playstation
exclusives like not that humorous
but um yeah what's your experience with
the game man like how much have you
played what you're feeling
you know kyle going to call it game of
the year
all right well for all those uh
playstation 4's your numbers better be
up i better not see the same four
million dudes i know
you know why after you broke sony fans
already brought one game this month that
other game got to go to the books
so i already know it's not going to get
purchased like that right and this is
true
because sucker punch does really good
stuff man from
um the the what is that infamous
infamous like cooper like all that stuff
yes
but i'm not looking at sly cooper all
right let's let's stop let's just
get that out of here um let's go right
back to infamous right let's go to
the famous for they they triple a
bangers
right and you know infamous has the
atmosphere has the feel
and it looks very nice so they can nail
it and they also
nail cinematic yes their facial
expressions their
conversations that they have with the
characters are fantastic
now never played uh infamous and you're
new to the playstation platform
i highly suggest you go pick that up and
go pick up the expansion
you can see exactly the pedigree of
punch
we got some real vicious landing coming
in um shout out to the trigger man with
the two dollar subject
ghosts is greater than witcher 3.
witcher 3
fighting and dialogue was trash
and there's a five-year gap between the
games yeah like
like to even make the comparison like it
is like you just looking for clicks like
that's it
slows on you too he said it's a well
solved super serious
situation happening in the story would
it make sense for jin to be cracking
jokes
what's going on he said he's not
cracking jokes
cracking jokes like levity
so he's gonna run around this world for
60 to 80 hours
and not crack a smile you know
i need y'all you keep getting kratos and
his kid can be walking up a mountain
with their mom's ashes
and have a little levity yeah and have a
[ __ ] head
dangling from the side of his of his
waist right
this game takes itself way too serious
um all right so
let's let's let's start off with um me
streaming half you
tcl frauds
all of you basic baseline basement
gaming
your individual and when i say basement
gaming that means you're a subpart
you're
in the basement gaming in the dishes
because
you have a pcl and you have a
playstation regular not talking about
your people
i know the playstation slim guy that's
the guy that has an xbox that brought a
playstation
and was like yeah you know i'm just
gonna be my second system when
triple a bang has come out so not shame
when you slim guys because
you guys had the choice between the pro
and the slim you won't slim because you
knew
that it wasn't worth it right you knew
shout out to you right shout out to you
being smart saving some bucks oh but you
tcl guys the basic dude baseline
baseline you guys
first of all you're not even seeing
these games how they was meant to be
seen
right so when i turned it on and my
joint says pro and i'm like
it can only be seen on a pro that might
hurt but you didn't see it
you don't know about it so i had to
bring that information to you
you don't have a pro now for you guys
that don't have
a pro and don't have a good television
let me tell you what hdr looks like
yo this game when the reflections hit
off the wall in a bouncy bra
you're not seeing it so all you out here
cap and talking about oh
it's looks i mean shut up you don't
that's not them they don't qualify
you don't qualify all right i'm gonna
talk to probably about the
million of you guys just the million of
you guys that actually you
can understand what i'm talking about
here when i'm playing y'all playing with
me right
now that's right let's do it right so
we're here and we're playing
what i've noticed about this game and
the suspicion of
[Music]
they got all these little polygons and
all these little tinsellations and those
little stuff cause you know i don't
program a game but i said it looks
amazing
it's moving the world is swirling um
when you're talking to characters and
you see the sweat dripping down their
face like they're in 2k
playing 2k you know when you're playing
two kids
hdr and you don't have a pro i don't
know what you're saying
but i'm gonna tell you what i'm gonna
give you i'm giving you the update right
all right so i'm playing the game and
i've noticed
everybody said uh you know combat in the
beginning there's a little hmm
okay world looks very nice they nailed
that aspect of it
you know walking up to a village and
finding a village and you know
everybody knowing exactly who you are
that's letting you know
it's a tight-knit community everybody
knows you
of this dude and the mongol
and you see them ravaging the towns and
stuff like that and
i'm not gonna front yeah it felt
beautiful yes right the game it flows
okay even though it's assassin creed
light all right anybody that's played
assassin creed you're not gonna marvel
at the interactions or the cinematics
because especially if you're playing on
an x you know you've
seen uh this stuff right but you haven't
seen it
told in this uh the cinematic format
right the positioning of the characters
the the thoughtfulness that went into
the eyes
locking and the the conversations that
are being had
like when he walks up to one guy and
it's like a bow dude
and he's telling his story i had to
throw it in the black and white mode
because i wanted to see you know
because we just some movies you know
we saw it in that manner i got my little
hat now i got my little straw hat
and i think i'm hitched right now i
think i'm gonna ish the clothing
the clothing options is fantastic
um but again i knew that this game was
going to come
it's coming right past the last of us so
those that sit on that emotional high
from game of the year
down to this it's kind of like finding
your footing again
right but also i say this right the
playstation is dead
after this game and after you finish
this you can
sell your playstation wow right and go
to get ready for the playstation 5
because ain't no coming for you guys
right
it ain't like you got services or
anything like that right
and remember they're one and done games
so once you already maxed it out
you platinum it's done right so
what i what i suggest which is if if if
if if you have a pro and you're gaming
like me right you you're
gaming at the highest right um at the
highest
highest i suggest that you download this
game now give it a day
give it a day because it's gonna take a
day for it to download
right now for a long time right and what
i suggest also
you use paypal uh uh uh
is this a review of this of the
playstation 4 or is this
i'm confused what are we reviewing sir
oh i just want people to
understand right when they're making a
prayer i want them to make the purchase
this is a very good game yes
i want them to understand to be cautious
in doing so
okay so this is a psa in getting ghost
receiver okay
you know king told me to download the
game and now this dude got a ferrari in
my name
i don't want that to happen so you could
you're concerned with the security
issues
here's a dollar for each bump on the
back of any
witcher 3 haters with your three the
goat
all loved though okay he had to declare
the name anything else we got so did we
catch up
yeah we have uh yeah we have
uh what is that we got cat i think we
missed big cloud
cloud is after yeah so we got big cloud
with the five dollar super chat the
actual battle scenes and go to sushima
are incredible yes they are
yes um what are we missing we have uh
black ronin
357 went from a tcl to
lg c9 c10 65 inch and it's night and day
yes it is
i will say destiny 2 and 4k on tcl was
amazing and looks even better now on the
lg on my one
x y'all think i'm shaming you guys i'm
not i'm just telling you y'all are
you know gaming and it's people out here
really stepping up the movement
god bless i'm so happy that you just
evaluated your situation
so you know without inspiration that's
what you're telling
have me and him at this conversation you
know as far as
i consider um environmental storytelling
i feel this is as close to breath of the
wild
and why i like breath of the wild where
is really
one thing listen y'all know i got
overwhelmed fatigued like i'll just be
real like y'all know y'all guys do the
assassin's creed that shot thing
for me when i start a game and you open
up the map and there's 65 different
icons on the map
i really want to turn it off i'm just
going to be on that's just where i am
it's just so
daunting so for me i guess the way
obviously yes i buy a few of japan
mongols that's this is this cognito it's
the ninja i will admit
however i will say the way it opens up
and the use of the wind to direct you
and
you just naturally want to see what's
going on just because of the world
whether it be
the wind telling you or a fox or a
little what you call it you know a
little bird or something like that to
the shrines or whatever
so that's the first thing um that was
really special to me
this true samurai business man like he's
got a conflict going on
with himself you know what i'm saying
and he's got to figure this out shout
out to old girl who's with him
you know she trying to show him the way
you know
yeah because what i love about the
antagonist is he's like yo bro we
studied your language we studied you're
going to talk about them yeah i'm sorry
but you know that's pretty much the type
of tommy on
and right now the character has an
internal conflict also
you kind of find out this he's kind of
[ __ ] with certain things but i go get
into that
but you find certain things out you're
like oh wow i didn't know this you know
what i'm saying so that's the first
thing about the narrative stuff i like
you know again just like king like you
were saying like
everything whether it be the the leaves
the cherry blob the physics the
the hdr the light like every environment
is very lush and distinct
you know what i'm saying and and i
definitely like that about that
shout out to the um the little haiku
meditation spots and
like that that right there i think
that's the levity that uh
rooms
she was like yo come here me what you
need to do is just come over to the spot
and i was like i see her walking but
it was no like follow me type of thing
and i'm
around like world and i came back and
she in a different spot i was like
what's she talking about then it was
like rest
i was like okay so we're going we're
going to talk to you all right so i'm
going to rest and he get butt naked
and then it would give you the fake full
turn around like we're going to show you
enos
that's the levity that i was talking
about you know
you know we we grew up on this stuff
like yeah the lord solved you know like
we would all
age uh i felt real channel we would all
pull together
to buy like movies like this right sit
in front everybody's got the drink we
chilling
you know what i'm saying lights low
black and white everybody pick like this
is for my era so this is like
the samurai game i've always won and the
fact that he's got the conflict to
possibly be a ninja
i always do so look it's early oh
there's some rough edges yes there are a
couple of rough edges right there
but i'm surprised man because it's like
you said ain't just like
i didn't realize how much fun i was
going to have with it because i just
can't
stop playing it's there's a hook to it
you know what i mean
yeah and the last thing i'll say is just
those face off
everything that was just done with the
cinematography so done so well
it gives you that epic feeling like
i'm a samurai and they do really do that
so shout out to sucker punch man
they really out here doing it real quick
but we got some super chat before we
move on let's get it
we got we got gamers played with the
fight out of super chat fact
our dna 1.5 is confirmed for ps5
they don't care what we talk about what
we're talking about
many already knew ghost of sushi may
have be purchased a ps4
maybe okay oh we'll meet with the 20
super chat
all stars have sold out of shea butter
already
this week may get rough then we have
whatever jump me we have slow mo
with the final school chat tcl core
demands one it demands one king david
to cease and desist with the slanders
playing our hb tvs are inadequate for
gaming yes
we are trying leave us alone
not feeling the bullying coming from
lord king
tcl corporation gave us a cease and
desist
i will never stop
then we have a stitch with the five
dollar super chat cog before i forget
you need some warlock a hunter
fashions just from you ugly warlock
wardrobe
i see them screenshots on twitter we
gotta talk
we understand what you need to do to get
where you need to be on thursday so
keep up the good work sir yes yes yes
it's super lit man
but look i mean that's what i got i mean
i'm sorry sorry
no no go ahead before we we'll end on
the good stuff well
yeah let's not just throw it in the
morning you have nothing bad to say
about a cog
yeah i did
oh listen i mean at the end of the day
like i said it ainsley said it perfectly
which was like you know there's some
little environmental stuff
there is shout out to the lack of hip
detection sometimes when you're going
through the trees
they don't you don't seem to want to
crash into them
[Laughter]
a horse tries to jump through upright
trees have you had that yet
like what are you even doing don't
listen i know you with your guys the
oh i know i wish you guys can't talk
about the horse physics yeah they cannot
i can't like this
definitely there's certain things you
can't talk about because it's a
five-year-old game
yeah let's let's let's bring it up to
assassin's creed cog you haven't played
none of the new assassins creed
right exactly
you know that no king is focused
for those like i said if you love this
ark you love this uh type of
storytelling in this genre
this is the joint for you and uh yeah
it's going to be fun man we got to get
on with it man
so before we get on with it though let's
end
and the samurai talk on on a fantastic
note
oh big shout out to playstation nation's
finest aka blaze
4k sony baby baby
hold on one second hold on one second
soft
i demand because we have 354
people here i demand you get those likes
up for what salve is about to give you
right now
yes sir because if any of the baseline
people
that you know they already already went
out there you already spent that
hard-earned 60.
somebody's about to do something for you
let's get along with please let's get it
okay shout out to blaze 4k for all the
love he's showing off
our chat today uh this is going to be
something that's reserved for
members of the realm it's very special
very special oh if you're going to join
join now
boy listen listen to my timeouts it's
off time out wait a second man
wait a second listen don't say i did not
warn you right now
i'm telling you right now go join put
that five dollars up we're gonna give
you five seconds
you go listen join the realm right
you're gonna want to do this
right now go stop get up mm-hmm and
remember i told you
remember i told you i don't see nobody
remember i told you
get us off so no doubt that once again
shout out to blaze 4k for this
wonderful donation in our chat today so
again members around patreon or youtube
members
the first patreon a youtube member in
the chat who tells me
the name of the sega master system site
timeout
listen right now all right so everybody
put this shield up for our new brother
that just journey around yes sir boogie
man
all right listen sir boogeyman you are
very intelligent dude
i want you listen guys i'm not playing
around
you heard what saul was about to do
that's great sir
he got busy crunching who's crunchy
the question the first patreon
or youtube member who tells us
in the chat the name of the
side-scrolling
samurai game for the sega master system
that's hard it's not that difficult
because ain't that man
oh my god
it's not difficult it's something called
google like
shout out to midway monster king stadium
today too didn't it
welcome to the realm my guy welcome to
the real midway
you just got yourself go to shima
hopefully it's not on the tcl
hopefully you got that pro we in this
together me and you hbo
let's do it together midway monster just
uh get at my dms lord stop iop i will
send you the coach for that
once again thank you to blaze 4k he was
not able to get the actual code for the
game because as we know playstation
makes that
excessively difficult so you have a
bunch of codes so you could be able to
pick up the game on the psn uh psn
network
so once again congratulations and and
thank you once again to blaze 4k no
doubt salute the blaze
somebody's messy somebody put out there
who's playing far cry 4 in 4k
before we get into it did we miss any
suggests i don't think so
we got let me see him go back we got
boogie man welcome to the
realm just remember at the end okay
that's it all right no doubt don't die
you already know so look we're gonna get
into it the main event
y'all know what y'all saw y'all know
what y'all hear from
oh y'all know what y'all hear from so
lord tim dawg the legend man what's
going on brother how are we doing sir
good good how are you guys doing happy
to be here all right guys
so we had to have him go we had an og up
in here this is a big week we know
you know the xbox games showcase is
almost
upon us but before we get into that i
want to talk about
the announcements made prior right and
uh what we had obviously this week
was um you know some information about
xbox or was it gay pass
ultimate and xcloud and stuff rolling
into you know the service stuff like
that so i want to start with you tip
though i'm like
let's start with the services leading
into and the announcements leading up to
the week what are you feeling what's the
energy with you with this
well i mean they announced uh obviously
xcloud is going to be in
with uh ultimate game uh game pass
ultimate
so i think that's something that um
probably everyone on this panel was
asking for
yes and uh you know you know i don't
think that people it would have went
over well
if if there was a charge to it obviously
there might be a standalone charge
in the pro in the if you just want that
but um
i think that was something that everyone
asked for so it was nice to hear that
that's part of their plans and they
announced that and
uh you know um i believe they announced
the next cloud's coming in
september okay okay so so that was the
big news they also
um there's some uh obviously there's
some rumors there's something going on
with the xbox live
yes that's what i would ask you to
because
that is a big thing right now a lot of
people are wondering
is gold going to go away then i think
people found some things about like rise
of right now
correct me if i'm wrong we can't buy a
12 month
or six months or six months only three
months
it like ends off in like september
yeah from what i heard and what i've
asked about um that this is uh
this is something they're gonna plan i
don't listen it could be that they
they're they're
planning to lose the pay wall and but i
think that would take time i think
what they're trying to do right now is
get everyone caught up to date as far as
if they are
an ultimate user or if they're not and
then i think at that time that they
they're going to do some price changing
um
i think we all hoped that they could
drop the paywall because
with what they're offering with ultimate
and game pass i think it's kind of
safe to say that they could probably get
everyone migrated over to this
that's an xbox live you know let's say
less ten percent
right and with all that and you're also
gaining people
um you could actually lose the pay wall
and if they could lose that multiple
play wall i i think everyone would agree
that'd be like freaking huge huge
news that would be a mic definitely so
um but what i'm hearing there right now
just trying to get everything like
uh you know they're also going to have
all access and we're going to hear more
about that next month
xbox will access uh it's not going to be
like
uh what i could say is it's not going to
be like last time it's going to be
on a much bigger level and
i think that uh if you're interested in
getting a series x
with game pass ultimate and all the
things that come along with that
uh just pay attention next month uh
you're gonna get a lot of information on
that so uh
you got xbox all access you got xbox
game pass you got xbox ultimate you got
xbox live and then you have xbox
x cloud so they're gonna have to figure
out how to like
similar to what they're doing with the
xbox one x
and discontinuing the discontinuing
digital edition
they gotta bring it down to where
there's two options or three options
and uh i think that's what they're doing
and hopefully
um i know there's a lot of speculation
um
they could have it where you know xbox
live
you know basically there's a if you
there's no paywall for the multi
for the for the multiplayer which i
think would be a huge move i think that
would differentiate
itself from sony and could bring a lot
of people back
other than that if they're not going to
do that i hope at least though
that they give you an option to do it
cheap
i don't think that it's right that you
know if you just want to have that you
should have to pay
150. yeah i i don't think that that's
the case i think that they'll
the the pricing is gonna it's all gonna
make sense just take a look it's gonna
take a little time
not fair enough let's get our aims in
man uh obviously we had this
announcement you know we also had the
announcement like tim said in reference
to
basically production stopping on the uh
xbox one x
so uh skews seem to be kind of
streamlined heading into this event so
what was your thought process
aliens on on both announcement with the
project x cloud
ultimate and also the skews of the
systems yeah so uh the skus i think is a
more simple announcement right in the
sense of
what i mean by that is they're
transitioning in the next genus tim just
said right you you can't have like five
and six options on the market right so
you you trail off
it's not that it's not that hard of a
concept we've seen that for generations
right so trail off get rid of that stock
and then you move in with your series x
and uh
lockhart um on xcloud i think it's
exactly what we wanted to hear right
is that i know all of us and probably a
lot of people watching are game pass
ultimate already because you're across
pc
you're across your console and now
you'll be on every device right so
combining that
as just another feature is you know the
funniest thing i saw on twitter all week
was someone had like a ship sinking and
they just said stadium
i would just think this is the death
blow
and i think i think that's exactly what
we wanted to hear i think they'll
probably do something with gold and
standard game pass at a cheaper rate
right um but to tim's point as well we
don't know what x cloud looks like if
you want to just get that feature by
itself but
if you think about xcloud in general
right it just
it holistically works with game pass
right i mean it's the package that
really
gives you the offering um from a digital
perspective so
i think this is great i think you know
you talk if you look at the whole
picture
of where xbox is going you guys know
i've written about this many times
but if you look at their their hardware
and you look at their services
and you look at their play at global
markets i keep
for some reason i keep seeing people say
they need to build more series x to sell
in japan
it's like no they don't no they don't
that's not the play to get the asian
markets
just stop it yeah it's not you know it's
not 1995 anymore
um the play is mobile and they're the
only ones positioned
to truly bring their ecosystem to mobile
and i think
ainsley what what you're saying is that
these uh
sideshow uh ceos they don't know what
they're talking about
i i love how king puts words with
people's mouths i love
how
you know what it is it's because i have
a translator in my ear
when he does the politically correct
joint the translator in mind
the play is brilliant and um then you're
gonna add all access on top of that
right get people in
like you do any other device where they
have to spend uh
especially with the the markets we're
talking about this fall in north america
with covet right
things like all access are going to have
a potential even larger impact than they
were is it is it only in north america
or the
um the program was going to be either
worldwide or or what
i like thought it's rolling it's rolling
out yeah what do you say
like xbox is you hearing that i i i
can't say the number but yeah it's gonna
be
vastly bigger than what it was so okay
okay okay okay it's not gonna i wouldn't
say global but i would say
pretty really good really good coverage
it's not gonna just be america
good in there i'm being funny right now
in their territories that they are
already in right now and not the initial
uh
launch territories right i
i don't know that i i just i kind of i i
can't say the number but i can say the
second time
it's no it's it's a sizable amount i
know you know
um so i would think that you would think
that the big hitters or the ones that
you want
are included you know obviously you have
america and then
the second biggest market you have uk
think of it that way you'd probably go
from that down to a certain amount of
number
uh for how many they have but it's like
when they originally did this one of the
biggest complaints was
oh well you know it's just an american
you americans get this
right yeah that's not the case it's not
going to be the case here
they basically they did two runs they
did it with the 360.
if you remember at the end of the
generation and then they did it
like through dell and it was really like
the last time they did it was like
kind of like you know i wouldn't say uh
half-assed but it wasn't really what you
would expect
now i think that what you want what you
expect meaning
multiple publishers and or like multiple
uh you know brick and mortar house
places and stuff like that
you know if they're if they're involved
in their ticket with this
uh you know let's just say you go to
best buy let's say
and they say okay you play with credit
card or you can pay
uh you know cash obviously or you can
pay through all access program
and then you say well it's your access
program and they'll say well do you have
a best buy card
and there you go it's basically it's
it's inclusive on your credit
or even if you have a credit card you
can do it but uh yeah
they they're like i said they're really
they think they're gonna talk about it
in august they're
really uh pushing all access we've even
seen it stretch out as far as like
amazon
and because prior i would say was
limited i felt limited to the microsoft
stores themselves
the program and then yeah now it looks
like they've they've gotten other
partners to kind of include this problem
so i do
i do see what you're saying tim it looks
like they're definitely trying a bigger
push continue again i want to get low
the ghost oh no you're fine oh you're
fine uh the only other thing i'm curious
about and i think a lot of people have
asked about this right is is how they're
going to deal with apple
because it's a less of a play outside of
north america but in north america
apple is you know 60 of the market or 40
of the mark whatever it is
um and so you know ios right now is
still a big question i know there's been
some behind the scenes kind of debates
on that front so
kind of curious where that sits but um
no i think
they are just positioned really really
really well going into this generation
with options for everyone i would um
really impressive let's get uh fred
basic with the toaster chat will console
streaming still be a part of xcloud
yes yes yeah it's the whole dna of it
salute the free actually yeah yeah we
actually missed one before yeah so i'm
gonna
take you yeah jw is a show two dollars
for the chat
it is the answer bug snacks i guess the
to my sensation
[Laughter]
oh christopher all right yo go ahead
king you gotta read it
this is this is for you okay christopher
well game pass edition series
have a credit card read
um actually no but this time you'll be
able to afford one
oh my lord jesus christ
we had a lot of announcements this week
you know you saw the skews you saw
the potential of ice cloud rolling in
you know to ultimate
you know what's your thought process or
these announcements prior
to the game showcase man they are
positioning and setting themselves up
to phase certain things out and certain
things in for the future they're
building for long
term something that's very clear that
that phil dominus maximus
spencer has been saying has been
you can play your xbox whenever wherever
however you like regardless of whether
or not you have an xbox they don't care
if they get you on xcloud
they don't care if they get you on an
xbox series x or lockhart
they don't care if they get you through
game pass for pc they want you in their
ecosystem
spending their money that's how they
penetrate different markets in india
korea japan
that's how they recapture north america
and uk
that they're working to build those
pillar systems
they they've got the services they've
streamlined the hardware they're phasing
out the one x and the all digital
editions logically
which is dope because it makes my
project scorpio and gear systems look
cooler
absolutely so so that's cool but they're
doing this
to position themselves to give anybody
and everybody whether
you want that series x premium king
david edition
whether you want to get on on that lock
cart and it be your second system
whether you just want to play on pc i
can play infinite on an xbox one
xcloud game pass for pc xbox one x
series x
whatever i'm playing with my friends
they're setting themselves up to have
that
and streamline their business models
accordingly reducing that
xbox live gold paywall yeah they need to
do that
they cannot do it snap the fingers
tomorrow they've got to phase it out and
honor
contracts honor legalities and as tim
tim
and ains have said prior it's a gradual
process they're working towards that
it makes sense they are setting
themselves up to have
everything except the ip which we get
the showcase
okay 15 studios that's their their
tactic
all right ghosts i feel you talking
about let's get some man soft king where
you at
these announcements prior to the show
man all right cool so first let me get
the game to follow us who chat just like
the surface created an entirely new pc
category so shall the surface duo and
it's
and it's trojan horse for the
non-console-centric markets
i.e asia and trojan hearts yeah
absolutely absolutely
so uh for me honestly like uh when it
comes to the game past
the uh that cloud stuff i from the
beginning i said like
for xcloud to be viable they have to
give it to you as a choice it has to not
you it's something that cannot be forced
on the consumer
in a way that takes away their agency in
the decision-making process
and this is exactly it if you're already
in game pass it's additive
it isn't something that that necessarily
taking away though some people are
interpreting it that way with
with the elimination of these uh of the
one year
uh whatever xbox live and the six months
right um
so i think it's fantastic i think that
that is the way you move that
you move the x cloud narrative forward
is to it you know
ingrain it at the bottom level into
everything that you do
right um so i think it's fantastic that
it's going to be in an ultimate
without any uh added uh sort of uh
monetary
uh sort of uh coming in from uh a
different person
excuse me somebody's talking to me on
the side shout out shout out to lady
song
i'm having two conversations in my head
hold on a second
i got you bro don't worry about it i'll
pick it up no okay no so uh so that's
that
um beyond that when you look at what
they're doing eliminating the the 1x
and eliminating the s i think there's no
greater indication that
a lockhart is real right it's real
it's coming sooner rather than later and
it's a machine that outpaces the the 1x
considerably
right and in terms of price point when
you look at the two machines they
eliminated that means that the lockhart
falls
to me in that 200 to 300 price range
which is insane for the machine that
you're getting
right right uh so i think it was
necessary to do that i know a lot of
people had arguments about oh you know
they're talking about they want you to
play
your games wherever but they're
eliminating two platforms for you to
play those games
um and they're replacing it with a
platform that is probably going to be
as cheap as the ones they're they're
eliminating and considerably more
powerful
yo slow so stupid sorry
so
but yo let me let me flip this back to
the battle before i give it the cat okay
about to get his balls off
but i want to ask you because one thing
i have seen tim
um aims and ghost is people say you know
what
i still don't know what if i don't want
game pass what if i don't want
chris cloud well i just want live now
i'm incurring
an additional cost it's technically
become
more expensive you know what like tim
what do you say to those people
you know in general that may feel that
this is not a bargain
that everyone kind of envisions it to be
in your mind then i would tell them in
your mind
and pretend it's not there
you know i mean i don't think that i
don't think that i think
you know when you talk about it it's an
additive thing it's something that's
just there
to basically extend your play time and
stand your
gaming it's not there to make any money
um you know listen in the standalone
sense
it's it's big because it can get to
markets like korea and
all these these other places but at that
at that point
it's you know you can either buy it
standalone if they have pricing for that
i guess in the future we'll know
um or not and other than that if it's
included in something
and no additional charge you know uh
i think you should just just either if
you don't want to use it and you just
it's not your thing
that's fine too but you know listen i
mean there's sometimes now i have a
situation where
i'm waiting for ios to get the the
the uh the actual games on it yeah they
only have one i mean
it's good but i don't think that ios is
going to open their store up i think
that they're just
just the way they are traditionally with
their store and everything like that i
don't think that they're going to allow
it
um so for me what i'm thinking is i'm
going to have to get
the note 20 when it comes out the note
20 ultra because i'm up
to get a new phone and from there i
really will
you know i mean i use it but i have a
note 9 but it's my work phone so i can't
use it
on the network on on cellular
network like because that's basically
stealing
i could use it i could use it in the
sense that i can use it on my own wi-fi
right but the fact is finding wi-fi
wherever you just don't do that you know
so once i get my real cellular
connection
yeah which is a huge advantage tim
because um i'm sorry i'm fine
let's go you're good bro you're good
yeah i'll just say which is a huge
advantage also people don't realize with
xcloud as opposed to a service like
remote player what have you because
what has happened is they now allow you
to use uh wi-fi
i mean it allows you to lose um 4g as
opposed to
just wi-fi only you know what i'm saying
oh shout out to the realm oh hold on one
second we gotta
solve you gonna handle that uh super
chat we we have christopher hart with
the five dollar suit oh yes yes
it's game pass dollar tree gaming going
to be a good strategy when game fast
prices go
up you still own none of those games
so so christopher hart right and i do
appreciate you every week oh shout out
to you recovering i'm um fantastic that
you're doing better
you know a lot of people don't know when
um this guy is missing i look for him
because a lot of these playstation
generals do
not do not stick their neck out like
this man pause
um uh chris when it comes to game pass
you won't know the true value because
you don't have an x you don't have uh
xbox uh when you get an xbox because um
they will put in a position where it's
going to be too tempting for you not to
have it
um when you do get an xbox and you do
have that three months of
game pass for free talk to me after you
do that right
and then you and i will be the best of
buds
brother because you will throw that
playstation so
far in the bushes oh my lord i'm and i'm
not lying to you you would use it just
like everybody else here and i
understand your fish your fears is that
your playstation turns into that
part-time
system that you see every two to three
years when a triple a banger comes out
like everybody else who has both systems
mm-hmm
fair enough real quick
again we got shout out put the crush in
the chat for big bad
mo joining the round
pressed up for the guy you know whatever
you want me but yeah so is it overblown
stuff ghost it ends as far as this whole
you know value are people really like yo
you know i don't necessarily want
game pass rolled into my thing you know
what you guys with that
it's not no if i want to play breath of
the wild and i refuse to buy a switch
i'm not playing breath of the wild
like
at a certain point that it becomes a
silly argument and i recognize we want
we want options as consumers but there
is a
there is a limit and they're providing
you
a ton of service you can have game pass
and still buy the game
like that is a thing that can happen but
you cannot fight the future like the
time continues to
march on us all and change is part of it
it just happens to us as we get older
like it's gonna happen
i can't i can't be mad that it's
happening i can only prepare for it yeah
don't fear love
and then we'll get kicked yeah it's the
same thing right you're talking about
removing the paywall eventually for xbox
live like they have in gold now right
and if you've got your bottom option as
gold and
and game pass and you're getting 200
plus games a month for
for ten dollars a month and that's too
much for you then you shouldn't be
looking at video games
yeah i don't want that value ames
how dare you give me value
if ten dollars a month is for over 200
games is putting you over the top you're
like i don't know if i can afford this
you shouldn't be gaming
go go work on something else
are you talking about the tcl dude
but i mean luke said there is a line
right
everything you can't deliver everything
for free i mean
they spend billions and millions of
dollars on it the value is already
the best in gaming as it is games even
if they did
you will have somebody saying man
for free it has to be some type of catch
yeah yeah so let's get a kickback all
these announcements
prior to the you know next week you know
where you at with the ultimate when it
came across your feed i saw your
reaction you got funny emojis
in the chat you know what i'm saying so
where are you at with this whole thing
and excuse me consolidated
all right so um first of all i would
like to have all those knees
that i told you fedex shipped i told you
guys a long time ago what was going on
you know um i'm not i'm i'm i'm i'm not
as privy to as much stuff as him
you know but i get some stuff too you
know and when i told you i'll ship your
knees
here you had to you had to listen phil
dominance maximus soon to be a really
expensive
has taken you from the dark ages and
then brought you to the light
and you guys really didn't understand
what he was doing because a lot of dudes
like grime i guess i'm going right at
you bro
i haven't seen you shots since you said
phil is this nice guy
since he's been on his world tour like
muhammad my man
he's been doing his busting shots wow
wow like and i'm loving every minute of
it so
every time you dudes you please complain
louder
get louder with your complaints because
every complaint
and like a true strategist every
complaint that you've had
he's yanked it out of your mouth all
right
so so now the first complaint was oh
xbox is behind the paywall you know if i
want to play my friends you know what
i'm saying
okay all right i hear you i hear you
shut up
yank that out of your mouth
that's right hit you with the spanish
right out of your mouth now you're like
oh man so now they can play with their
friends over there without the pay wall
yeah man fortnite is over there oh
fortnight is over there looking better
i'm out right so now
these are things that had to happen
right so you dudes are saying like oh
they're they're discontinuing the xbox
one x
okay they discontinue in the digital
okay
like saab said they're removing
to add more right right so the lockhart
will slide in
where the uh digital the sad edition is
at right
and it will give you more value
it will give you more power and it will
probably do so at a cheaper price
right we don't want to uh
confuse the consumers this is what
they're saying right all right so let's
remove this uh because a lot of you guys
that was that was a big one
people were gonna be confused remember i
said drinking stuff out of your mouth
remember this is the yanking part this
is the part you're not good with your
tonsils is bad so he's removing it
are you trying to say he's removing all
these concerned narratives
is that what we're doing all the fake
concern watch how i break it down for
you
guys are going to be disgusted with it
all right
so now it removed that whole oh my god i
don't know what to purchase grandma
trouble
for christmas what she's going to get
five excuses
so now that's removed right now granny
can do what she got to do
i i like my grandson but i don't love
him let me get the lock hurt please
those dudes that have more than the tcl
those dudes that expire to be better
let me let me have that top shelf right
there thank you
please right so all right do you have
top shelf dudes and you have bottom
basement dudes
in between your court in between you're
there right either way you're gonna game
now a lot of dudes talking about game
pass
right right game pass which is probably
no i'm not gonna say probably i'm going
to say it is the best gaming system on
the
game service on the planet
sorry none let's say you guys let him
you can go real loose yeah you left me
alone i got
jumped and it goes to sema topic sir
left me alone don't don't tell me much
right anyway
um okay so now we know that
it's the best service on the planet
gaming
service bar none the next competitor
which is the playstation now is in the
bushes with the two million dudes
we got two million dudes that actually
showed up to the party two minutes
and we rocking what 15 17 dudes out here
million
dudes out here like it's different kind
of parties babies different kind of
parties
all right well now you got that game
pass right
they say yo all you beta dudes come
september everybody gonna get it thank
you for testing it
how much it's gonna cost free i told you
i want those knees i told you if they
were just gonna throw it in there and
roll it up in there right
so now you have game pass right but now
when you pop up your phone and you was
playing on your system
you're standing in because you got to
leave you got you have to run out of the
house but you're at this board
on neon abyss that you want to get past
but you're inside uh trying to pick up
your package at fedex
because i got needs coming in so i'm
right there i'm like man but i'm
on my phone playing neon abyss right
while i left off at xcloud 4g
what happened what was that that's some
stadiums that they was trying to do
right
didn't work out it was right because the
infrastructure wasn't right yet but this
is when true planning comes in right
this is when
true planning phil dominance maximus
soon to be a really a spencer
takes the lead and brings you from the
darkness into the light
now can't sound like a scripture
you dudes are complaining for them
giving you
value here's the ultimate value
this is where the broke dudes i'm
yanking all that money talk out your
mouth let's go
we don't know how much it cost king we
don't understand
financially right now the world is in
the turmoil i feel you i hear you
you know who else is you microsoft um
you know what they said
they got a program for you which one
before we talk
we're talking about the program uh
what's what's the name of the program
access all access
what does that mean see did they say
limited access
they say minor access no they
who is giving you this accent who's the
access for
it's for all it's for to do that
financially right now man it's not
working
okay well we have a program that'll work
for you and you can pay this off shortly
oh for real i can go home with it right
now right now sir
[Laughter]
can you help me take my game into the
next level yes we can
so this is not an exclusive thing that's
locked behind a paywall like spiderman
oh yeah this is not an exclusive thing
that's locked behind
fake narratives like oh it can only be
done on this platform
and after seeing what y'all did with
that controller bruh
i saw that game did you see the game
where was the graphics at
oh i scored load times too i saw load
times on something that was built inside
the system
so again the ssd not working right the
graphics is in the bushes yeah are we
are we gonna admit it should not even at
all but as far as the uh dude
as far as uh ssd wasn't doing what we
was told and uh yeah
no no it's being legit like people
sitting there acting like this ssd is
godly it's gonna make no
loading screens and there's seven second
loading screens in the beta
can we wait to see an actual game but
that that's
that's a game that comes with the
playstation okay
so you needed to tell me that if it
can't do with the game that comes with
the console that is designed to show you
what the console does
it's going to do it with something else
listen y'all messy right now i had to
get this over here we got
we got
is access for all yes all right in
conclusion
game pass for all in conclusion
you're getting more value from one
company
that understands the market like no
other
so when i have fake narratives keep
complaining
because all you're doing is ripping it
out of your mouth so you have nothing to
complain about
and soon you're just going to be
standing there alone with you
and your little hands sticking out like
i don't know what else to say he did
everything that i was complaining about
no doubt the pocket watch you're
concerned fair enough look let's get uh
jd gamer we have to find our super chat
samsung
hopefully the eu convinces or sues apple
into allowing competing apps onto their
store
then we'll see xcloud for real yeah we
got to see i know they have very
stringent policies so if you want to get
the next one
we have regulator with the two dollar
super chat we might get the mic drop
free gold don't forget no doubt no doubt
i hit a horse someone did join
shout out to midway monster follow super
chat i was just charged by gold
membership
what happens to us that just got charged
if gold is getting
integrated into the game past tears
which and
and i think that's the reason that they
disabled one years
like if you notice you can't get a year
of game pass anymore
i think i think the reason that they
disabled that is because
they're like look like this isn't going
to be here for a year
so why sell it for a year like no doubt
i honestly i i really do i think gold's
about to go
like there's just there's a lot of con
normally i would be like nah that's too
much money
but there's a lot of there's a lot of
people like this
okay there's a lot it cares that it's
going like there's literally no reason
to get rid of a year
on the on the marketplace and they did
unless they know
that if if it's longer than a year
they're gonna have to refund it so
yeah we'll see what happens let's get a
finish up we got yeah
with the 10-pound super chat please say
something brother yes um
then we have j dub as a shill with the
final super chat
does anyone know if the ps5 can
consistently and
safely safely
do 4k 60 frames per second you can uh
need to know if i should pre-purchase
fire insurance before buying a vip
get in the single ship put it right next
to it it should be the same height
there we go regulated with two dollar
super chat king did it again r.i.p to
chris's knees
his knees are gone man i like chris
chris is a good dude
i'm selling wheelchairs on all access
and you know what you got you guys are
going to want our wheelchairs man they
got the iop logo on the side
with my face on the sidelines i've done
viper xt the canadian five dollars did
you hear the playing station four pro
look at that uh king he completely
wouldn't borrow a wheelchair statement
he said the ps4 pro is now the most
powerful console with the xbox one x
production ending
nice new avatar tim dawg all right
okay okay okay um gaming for today with
the two live super chat been saying it
for months xbox live will be free
soon no doubt what else we got uh let me
see we got pixel [ __ ] with the five
dollar super chat
all the fear pushers can kick rocks
barefoot tyler
let them save those uh crocodile tears
for the 23rd discount the knees
who did that for you eloah i did that
for you right quick
hit picture with that oh then what else
were you all caught up look richard
uh what's his name
god bless king he always gives xbox
credit when they deserve and sends all
the haters to the pony nether realm
new to the podcast i am a fan now
super panda yeah we got before we need
viper xt
but let's put them crushed
super chat seven second load times told
everyone to watch and see
yeah letting it go i know that for sure
then we have
fred amazing with the two dollar super
chat first time chilling my last name is
muzzy music music music okay
we got it really we gonna get it right
now we have
red music thank you very
oh actually we have a few more actually
yeah
superman we have super panda with the
five dollar super chat on this lord's
day let's have a small moment of silence
for stadium going
forward out for the homies
it was a good run it was a good run for
dale then we have the the apostle of the
book of ex smitty smith himself with the
final super chat
p.s fanboys sir my back hurts this goal
post is heavy
jim daniel's round
still over y'all
tell krista he can keep that one and a
half our dna ps5
wow look big announcement
i thought it was cool you know prior to
the show you know to get these kind of
things out
and um let's just get rid of it i agree
with all you guys everything everything
has been said already i completely agree
i think it's it's great value i think
they are setting up goal to somehow be
phased out
i think it looks like maybe the writing
is on the wall with that but it would be
a huge process through the move and
definitely worthy of its own
announcement
but we got to get into something i'm
glad
413.
i'm about to drop something in the chat
as we say goodbye to the ps4
uh the lord would like to give to
someone in the chat
with uh one of the games that defined
the ps4 era so the first one to grab it
now go get that go get that go go get
that boom
use paper there you go anyway but yeah
we're gonna get to it man we'll get to
it so look i'm glad addict is here he's
in town because
this one has been a highly
highly contested argument of books
xbox fans prior to the show so let's get
to it man
the thing right now we know this is the
stakes are high this is one of the
biggest
showcases in xbox history and the
question that comes across
my line is how should they
start what should they start with so i'm
gonna give it to attic first as you take
it this is something we go
at it you know say so addict what needs
to be
first i would say anything that
if halo isn't first i'd be very
surprised you know
if if fables first that would
that would be interesting because i i
have no clue what they would end up with
all right so so in your opinion fable
being first would be the good look or
you want to
it would be it would be a good look
because it would show me that
i don't think they're going to end it
with halo under no circumstance
so it would show me that they have
something better than
everyone but if they it's a i'm sorry
they end with halo to now
why why is it because i talk about it i
feel like you ending if you ending with
halo that means you're trying to put the
whole show on halo's
back and that's just my opinion you end
it with something that you want to
to stay in people's minds for the long
term you don't end it
guys but in the short term you want halo
in their mind because that's what
they're going to be playing in a couple
of months
i get that but everyone knows halo you
should you keep that for the
the bam you don't keep that for the oh
we knew that was here
i'm ted this is a hot one i've talked
this
amongst many xbox fans this is super
polarizing
how they i guarantee you i i guarantee
you if if they end that with halo
the show's going to be bad i i honestly
think
world go ahead talk get your balls off
let's be real here it's if they're
ending with halo
and they're putting all this pressure on
halo what else are they going to show at
that point
didn't you just make a video about how
halo it has all the press in the world
running like
no that is that is the quality of the
game being good that's not the show
everyone knows halo halo is i'm not
saying it's dead but halo's definitely
not where it used to be
but can we honestly say everyone is chat
no let me talk let me just
tell you are you saying that halo is not
gonna be that
everyone in this chat is always saying
i'm tired of gears halo and forza
why are they gonna end it with the stuff
we know why they're gonna end it with
the stuff so all right
where where should in your opinion even
though this is not a subject
where should halo be placed in europe
halo needs to be
at the beginning okay and they need to
end it
i mean you can laugh all you want oh i
mean if they're relying on them
if they are relying on halo there's
something wrong because why
why are they relying on the cell phone
you know all right let's see let me get
you
you leave the end for a mic drop moment
i'm sorry in no way
shape or form is halo on my drop moment
right now let me get ghosted he's
shaking his head so hard at you i need
to know
why the ghost is angry with addict let's
go ghost man okay so there's a cut
the reason i'm angry with addicts about
this nonsense
the idea is that's all you want let him
get his balls the idea
objectively no i don't think it should
be ended there but
we don't know everything does rest on
halo they have said
phil thomas israeli's suit thank you
king
that they plan to launch with a halo
something that's not being done since
the original xbox
they said that everything rests on this
it does they know that they need that
god of war moment now
i agree with addict halo should be early
in the show but let me tell you how
they're going to start
and then we hear phil spencer's voice
xbox backward compatibility coming to
xbox one then he took xbox game pass
coming to xbox one
xbox one s xbox one x they take us
through
okay the good legacy sizzle reel
and they end that scissor reel of
showing us games of all those good
moments they've had
since 2015 legacy awaits
[Music]
you know legacy awaits and they show us
then through the show
the xbox legacy that they are building
they've shown they've they're they're
honoring their legacy with smart
delivery and background compatibility
they're building it with new ip
put cyberpunk and halo early in the show
okay
the way you mic drop end it you mic drop
end it
after all the fables and the perfect
darks and everything else but you killed
it
your whole argument said it's at the end
and now you're saying something else
you're confusing me ghosts you're
confused
man these people talked over me for 10
minutes
actually i didn't actually i i shut up
and i let you spit your spew
i did it he got it to me all the time i
didn't know
i did it i owed it i owed it come on we
we move it at like 60
60 interrupts per second 60 ips come on
now let's get back on focus
there's no l if halo's at the end is
where i'm taking issue but they
end it with very quick
batman cape over a wb logo
see you in augusta
[Music]
this is a big one tip though the xbox
community is very
split with this wherever you talk i need
the og to tell me what do
you need them to set off the showcase
with
well um i would love to see halo
yeah i think i think that's what
everyone really wants to see they want
to see game play
one of the criticisms of the last show
was they didn't have gameplay
it was valid i can see them though
uh you know i'm hearing it's gonna be a
lot of gameplay
10 plus minutes of uh of campaign
so uh that's gonna start off the show i
think it's rumored to start off the show
one little tidbit watch the pre-pre-show
yes
uh because there's gonna be a lot of
information that they can't
put in this the this stream this stream
is probably
mostly game trailers and games um
and possibly some sizzle reels like uh
luke was saying
um but yeah there's gonna be a lot of
information in
the pre-the pre-pre-show so i would
definitely watch that
just uh as a side note to sit say if
it's
what is it nine o'clock or is it twelve
o'clock yeah twelve o'clock eastern nine
percent so
set your clock an hour back because
um especially if you're interested i
think they might talk about where
they're gonna talk about 120 frames per
second
i think they're gonna show it in
obviously in in the uh
in the main thing but they might also
talk about it and list titles that
they're adding
um okay one of the titles that
we all know is ori that's gonna be i
heard that's native 4k60.
okay okay uh you know then you got like
forza horizons possible you got a bunch
of the games that
they're gonna push out so a lot of the
little like um
like little things that you know you
would miss um
just watch that pre-show but yeah i
think you're gonna show off with halo
and
uh it's gonna be uh you're gonna learn a
lot of things and it's gonna be a big
a big uh you know big thing of
information
i think halo fans are going to go crazy
i'm hearing it's really looking good
uh hearing that it has some real like if
you old school halo 1 fans
and that that crew that felt like that
you know 343
and everyone took it too far whatever
they didn't like the sprinting and this
this
the shooting and all that uh the the
sprinting and the
um you know the uh what a thrusting and
all that stuff
uh i think that they brought this back
to the uh
the original theme where master chief
was focal and
um you know that was it's just i'm
hearing halo one to three vibes
okay uh from this game so uh
yeah i think we're in for a treat um and
uh
as far as the rest of the show i don't
know if we're going into that now but um
i i you know they gotta hit it they got
they gotta hit it yeah
we're gonna get into that part we look
at that let's get aims aims was also
shaking his head i thought
but uh i need to know where that is we
haven't talked about this you know
setting
it off one of the most highly
anticipated showcases in
microsoft xbox history what do they need
to set it off with for you
you know i'm kind of weird on what first
of all we got i gotta touch on halo so
hold on a second
all right because halo
there's all this misconception that
halo's not what it used to be i'm so
tired of hearing that phrase
it is if anything bigger given the
market
bigger than it used to be because
it's now on pc every time they release a
single game in the master chief
collection
where does halo sit on steam that's
right that's right number one
right let me give you some millions of
three just hello three just taught us
that
again and so did halo 2 anniversary and
so did when it first launched and so did
reach it hit number one
every time that's right and that's for
10 and 15 and 20 year old games
halo infinite launching on series x as a
showcase title right which we know it's
going to be
still launching on xbox one being on
game pass and launching on pc
all at the same time halo's gonna take
over the world so you better be prepared
for it
that's it's right for content creators
to stream to forge forge mode on pc
that's gonna let them share stuff i'm
sorry ain't i'm excited
it's every single category checked for
the for the opportunity for halo
to return to the mind share greatness
the numbers
he's right uh and we would be killing
ourselves
if we talked about halo's mind share but
it's poised to make a huge comeback and
the dorks like me who read the books and
stuff
we can see it lined up miles away it's
there sorry
it's go ahead no no hey they love it
because shout out to dizzy by
former ceo of lordsgaming.net he said
putting in my resignation at long day
and joining seasons gaming
he is so not about what i want he knows
where we go at with this so he is so
about what you talk about continuing
so anyway i had to set the halo record
straight now i'm kind of weird
we're talking about opening the show
right yes let's goalie this is the one
so i'm
i'm kind of weird i'm different from
everyone and i talked about this on our
show yesterday so i think they're going
to open with something that is
familiar but um we hadn't seen yet that
appeals to a bigger audience so for some
weird reason just in my head and it
probably won't happen but i'm going to
say it anyway
i think they're going to open with eldon
ring
and the reason i say that is we haven't
seen it yet right
people it's a from software game people
are super happy
with someone else's stuff i'm going to
have
issues with that this is the thing it
didn't have issues with everything
huh
come see our stuff but the first thing
gonna be someone else
that makes it better than a rockstar
xbox game showcase
it's not first party showcase you're
talking about xbox
people oh my god
calm down
so the only reason i say that is uh
similar to
it's cyberpunk's its own world right so
i think we may see some cyberpunk too
but
i think they open with this because
people are dying to see gameplay from
software is huge
um we know they have the marketing deal
for it it showcased last year right the
premiere of it the
teaser video did and we know there's
going to be third party games here
now you know to addict's point when you
when people reflect on this show i think
the whole
thought of if this game's in minute
eight and this game's in minute 47 it's
a loss it's the dumbest thing i've ever
heard
people are going to reflect on the whole
show what games were shown what did they
look like what gameplay did we see
what do we know as releasing in launch
window how does it compare to sony
showcase that's what people are going to
look at who cares when the game actually
shows
um i think there is something to be said
for how you open the let hey
hold on hold on we'll see who cares let
halo end it i guarantee you if halo's
ended in this thing
they don't have a whole lot to cat
payload i don't want halo 3
release his bars i literally
i'm just going to be on my mic
no i'm not talking the rest of the
podcast i'm not talking
oh because he want to spit his bars and
they don't talk over me please let me
release myself
and then when somebody else is talking
he's but i'm telling you [ __ ] mean
well i already said the piece on hey it
doesn't matter where halo is in the show
halo is going to come out and yeah
it's going to wreck it it doesn't matter
um but no i anyway my point being
i'm weird i know i think they're gonna
open with something that's familiar but
appeals
outside of just the xbox audience i
think that's the peel of eldon ring okay
that's the only thing all right all
right okay that's
that's a spicy let's solve man um
okay don't get to know again this is my
opinion is
that i understand what alex is saying um
and and for the most part he is right
but i do think that
you can't really make an ultimate
ultimate statement like that
because you never know they could just
what if they just [ __ ]
they went crazy and they just said fable
they showed up city and
they showed uh you know um you know
another new ip and the triple a and this
and that they went really crazy
and ended it with halo i don't think
anybody would be
uh upset or say that it's it's
you know but i think what he's saying is
that if it is
ending it shows lack of uh you know
announcements but
i think honestly i i really i feel
strongly that that i don't think that's
going to be the case with this
show i think you're going to get you
know we're gonna talk about this
in the upcoming segment but you know uh
it's
it's it's gonna come okay so and the
bottom line is if the game looks good we
won't care
right it takes one game to win a show
gamers are
fickle like that you know i mean
the the thing is i think the most
critical thing is halo show as well
imagine it didn't yes right wow that's
good
like we got a problem that's right yeah
that's what i mean it doesn't matter
where they show halo if it looks good
it's gonna it'll be fine
fair enough fair enough solving we'll
get your balls off man i mean you
haven't talked about this
you know what what do you think is
critical for them to start with
i think well going into the pre-show
right i think the pre-show
is where maybe you you shadow dropped
something like battle toads
like some battle toads or maybe even 12
minutes
things that we've been looking forward
to on the id at xbox side
um and then for the show proper i i
believe in sort of building
up momentum so i mean
but still showing us something first
that comes from xbox that we haven't
seen yet
so if forza is a thing start with forza
right
then then then whatever you're going to
sprinkle in after that
then you go forza then you go um
uh what you'll call it uh you get into
hell well you get into hellblade exactly
then you get into help you show me some
gameplay of hellblade then you go that's
then you go into
to me fable is should be right before
halo
i think halo ends it because my my
reason for thinking the halo ends it is
this is the game you want people to
focus on
that they're going to be playing when
the system launches right
so if if you're not confident in what
you're showing now
you should be someone like like tim knox
said he's expecting 10 minutes of
gameplay
to me that is what that is the game that
shows you the reason why you want this
system
now okay let me let me flip it on you
for a second just for the
i know we've had dizzy probably since
you agree with you but
what about for those who say like okay
we know it's coming this year
and what about two you know people who
say look this is a microsoft staple
right we kind of know them for the halo
the gears the forza
and like ending with like something i
don't want to say that gives hope but
of something new what do you say to that
crowd no i just i think you put too much
stock into the actual
event and then like ainsley said that
you're going to think about the event as
a whole afterwards
after all this stuff comes in if they
show fable
if they show it in a good light you're
going to remember fable
you're not gonna unless i remember if it
comes out at the end and after the show
it's gonna be its own thing
it's gonna have its own videos twitter
accounts its own social media
presence i mean to me to me
a mic drop moment that would sort of
supersede all of this stuff to me
is what ghost said like if you if you
get that if you have those wb studios
and you have that
then you end with something like that
just a quick tease just a quick like
just a hey it deals
we're not ready and i'll show you
exactly and you do that right after so
if halo shows fantastically and people
crying clapping and whatever
and then you show that afterwards you're
going to lose their minds
come out with a batman left field
no but i just think it's funny how like
we all of us are just imagining it but
we're still imagining it in the e3 forum
but you know with coven everything sucks
this gives them the opportunity to
absolutely there's nothing live right
control the narrative and they need
they've always needed to figure out how
to do mic drop moments like
somebody's very good at that they've
been super good so
it's now that they have the time to sort
of figure it out and sort of place these
things where they think they would shine
the best
i still think to me it's like you put
halo at the end because this is the show
piece for this year this is we want you
to buy this machine right
this is why you buy this machine and
everything else beyond that because
again
if fable isn't coming soon okay question
question
if if as tim was saying there's there's
10 minutes of gameplay
that is a long time
so if you've got a 10 minute segment or
even let's just let's say 10
tim we heard some approximation it's
down to seven but
that's a long time uh is the is that a
lull like do you end on that
like what if if if the if it's a
vertical slice
that constantly ramps up the wow factor
then you're good i think you're good and
it ends on on
one of those you know classic master
chief moments saying something like
i'm going to fight or something like
that get ready
get ready pickles man look at me
that's why i don't under understand
attic stance because that's addict's bag
that's what he wants to see he wants
master chief
against the world like this is what you
want to see and if they do that right
ending the show on that is going to make
it going to make people go bonkers to me
that we need to fight moment that was so
good right yeah
i talked he's not talking now but i
think
he's bad i think his overall point was
if they're showing this to end the show
that they don't have any other
announcements like but
the other announcements have come before
right if you show me
like if you don't show me your favorite
if you don't show me fable i'm gonna be
mad at you
i'm crazy fair enough that's true
i got i gotta speak to my homie right
now i gotta i gotta speak to the king
okay okay we ready
we're ready hey this is phil dominus
time
i need to know no my guy
we wrote history oh my god my guy
rewrote it let me put this up one for
you like talk of this
he rewrote the road map that dudes had
like
when when because i put a picture up
when i when i first met him and i looked
in his eye we had a conversation
and i knew from i knew from that moment
um
my franchise halo
my chosen box my box of of choice
xbox was it was great hands
because what i saw looking back at me
was a gamer
that was concerned that this is the last
beachfront
like i saw atari go i saw click ovision
go i saw on television go
i saw bedrick's goal and um
i seen them die i seen companies die
and it was and it wasn't uh from
the outside source it was always innards
right that killed them it was always
from within they died
right all right so seeing them
we had a conversation at e3 and it
they ended it on um what was that stupid
ip
um anthem and
at par for the course every e3 made him
have the conversation
after the fact right first i would like
to apologize to you
uh phil dominus maximus spencer soon to
be aurelius
i would like to be i would like to
apologize to you
uh for not for following but for not
understanding your wisdom at last
you you asked me and last year the
question
uh and shout out to tim dawg for you
know getting me
to stand because it was a hell of a line
yeah
tim's the man well that's a cheat right
there well you were like you're like no
i don't want to cut the line like shut
down
for real just like what he just said i
said no i didn't want to cut the line
because there's so many people
that wanted to have the conversation
with him and i've been blessed to have
the conversation but
um tim knew every year i guess i don't
know if you know he has words with him
and
you tell him yo i want to know what what
my guy thinks the dude that had my back
when
everybody was asking questions a woman
he asked me well what did i think and i
said this is your moment i don't
want to step on it and you know from
reflection back i looked at it i was
like okay
i see where he went with it i understand
strategy
so i asked him at the end with anthem
that year and i said
why did you end because he said you know
how did you feel about us i got one
question for you why did you end on
somebody else's ip
i remember that and he told me business
and i said thank you
that's it we don't have to have no more
conversation because i understand
business
right um i think that's stuck in his
craw
okay i think i think i think that stuck
in his crawl that this is the most
important
showcase this is his
box that he's stepping forward with this
is his
generation that he's starting this is
his
showcase now when i say his i mean the
team
yeah right the team but under
his leadership
he'll end on halo
he will end on halo just the same way
sony ended on alloy
he will end on halo knowing exactly
what it means now
i know you guys saying well alloy we
y'all knew it was coming but see here's
the absolute complete difference
this is when a boss make the real moves
talk to me
you're playing this game this year when
the system launches
you're not playing alloy no time soon
all right no time soon but so what do
you know
i'm gonna get you to start with
y'all heard spider-man and y'all didn't
believe i didn't believe either
i didn't know what that was but i can
tell you this ain't gonna be no
repackaged dlc
damn so you want to shoot shots shots
will be shot right back at you
fable will start it off wow look this is
this is powerful stuff that elva's got
the holy world the scripture the chat
was definitely in in pocket with you
right there look
this is a big one i am weird i am
different
y'all gonna be mad so here's the deal
i get what y'all saying if it's fable
i'm not upset
if it's halo i'm not upset i get it you
know you set the tone
you let them know what we call it i saw
meat on the table
i get it i get it for me
and this i'm gonna stick with my mantra
it's always been
just one and for me i would like
to see something new that's why the
third party showcase
kind of excited me because i believe it
was bright
memory infinite or something like that
and i was like oh
what's that oh it's that kitty
you know i said it's mature because that
was the the talk so it's exo right it
was too many
you know whatever whatever cog is
perfect dark
new for you or not according to the
fanboy rules
let me give you a question so you asked
a great question ghost and i have to
break down the fanboy rules as to why
they don't count that they don't count
perfect dark they don't stop
yeah the fanboy rules say it cannot be a
sequel
it is we have news yeah tim know the
fact you i see your twitter timeline tim
i see it
right these are what they tell me so
again
it it have to be first for me i just
want it there that's my overall for the
thing
but i would like this is just me selfish
if they could
show something new that we didn't
necessarily expect a new ip
and it just looks good just to say okay
you know what
you came in here thinking you just gonna
get you know big mac
large fries and a coke no you're getting
this right here we got mcrib
we got we got all this you know what's
it like just to show
the plethora the diversity that yo this
is a new day again
but if they show i'm not mad don't get
it twisted i
honestly don't it's for my man addict i
know he's not talking on voice strike
right now
but for what i would for him
i would love them to show fable because
he's waited so long
for it you know what i'm saying and and
just to show that it exists
it's there that would be a good look
that's well that's what i think i heard
you chirp is uh go say and solve i'll
give it back to y'all i heard you
tripping for a minute
and then we get the super chats you all
good
no no no no i was good i just wanted the
clarification of like
when you say new we're talking new ip
and let's not let's give due credit to
sony when
they gave studios like gorilla and
insomniac
chances to make something new and we
know microsoft's all about letting the
the
creators the developers make what they
want to make so i'm excited for what we
don't know way more than what we do and
i think that's kind of the same
point you're trying to make that that
exciting because i love
tim knows this man tim we've been around
the block
and there's nothing that hurts more than
that
week of and you kind of know what it's
been leaked
right oh yeah yeah i think this is the
first show
we could honestly say like we still we
got some feelers here and there
right but we don't really know no no no
no no no
and i love that guy and i think one of
the things that
that happens and you know we listen this
year's sucked
you know what it's been horrible
absolutely but the ability for them to
have covet
means that guess what they don't have
these they don't have i remember you
remember the one in 2016 where they did
the
they did their pre-show and a security
guy yeah
called up somebody and said the whole
show said the whole show
so like there's usually there's
rehearsals and there's things that they
have to do
it's very hard to keep the leaks
especially like the last two days
right now in the cobin world we're we're
just
we're out of the loop so yes i think the
potential for that to
surprise us is uh is there and and one
of the things that uh and we're going to
like i said we're going to
know this next subject uh what what he
said about
japanese support i didn't think that
that that came out of nowhere so
they might have something there too
absolutely absolutely
yo let's get the chat we missed a bunch
i got a regulator what we got
no we got no we're
just don't start with the current gen
game yeah
or past gender game like gran turismo 5.
oh damn shots what else you guys saw
okay hold on it's about to jump me real
quick it's gonna jump me
that daddy i believe i got regular oh
fred no we got fred
music i would prefer splinter cell over
perfect dark okay
okay uh jonathan b alright we have
enabled this for far
too long addict's world must be
destroyed oh my god
jesus continue and we have viper xt
with the uh five canadian dollar super
chat halo to start fable to finish or
vice versa
works for me but how would you like it
if they finished off with a surprise
splinter cell
exclusive yeah oh the tip you got your
batman michael you gotta go
we can't forget the pre-show what will
they show i have that no no no no it's a
whole
okay so yeah it did jump me um so we
have regulated 9.1 we have to out should
we have to out show sony's best which is
buck snacks
then we have wilmy with the 25 hours
phil is going to come out with an
iop hat and a batman cake let me tell
you something let me let me tell you
something if he comes over the iop head
i'll probably fat
you will probably see me just fall out
complete on air
[Music]
i will pass out i will be upset but if
it's if it's the one that we gave him if
he comes out with the shirt we gave him
not not the tee spring joint i want him
to feel dominance in the back
um have will me again with the 20 super
chat
barely king says unt verily king says
unto thee
hey butter on the back of the knees
remember
and remember this lord's day and keep it
in the book of
the book of acts you got the holy word
today
the apostle will be okay we got gaming
forte with the follow-up super chat
break up the trailers opening cinematic
over the course of the show
halo uh put five to ten second clips
between the announcements of other games
then end with halo that's another thing
they could do they could start off
with halo and leave you and give you
like a cliffhanger
and finish it out to finish the show out
with it that's
amen king david respectfully i disagree
at it
thank you brother thank you we have cat
daddy with the final super chat
silenced addict hashtag
yeah it did feel like he was leaving
abruptly but yeah
please leave known games for jeff's
pre-show yes yes
i agree all attic with the super chat
silence daddy let me get this file
i disagree with all you let's just end
the show with lucky tales too
he's so messy right now he hates the
fact that he's super jaded oh my god
he's hilarious
there we go poetic exhibition here with
the two dollars in the chat
please no bleeding edge cell phone leaks
yes please oh that was bad that was bad
that was bad
we all caught up we're caught up i don't
know what we missed in the middle
because yeah sorry guys yeah
we jumped a lot it's a hot one we'll
take care of it next week i know attic
is gonna
run through the runner show and you're
right
we'll be stupid attic is cancelled
let's get to it now this is the big one
you know obviously the show itself
you know and um you know obviously you
know the marketing is here we
we've heard from greeny greeny has said
we need some dude thank you well shout
out to phil for telling him to step his
camera up
yeah like he actually put out some stuff
and it really surprised me the first
thing was like look
i just want to say as he seen wild
expectations he said that this show has
one focus games no business
devices or similar news just
one hour long focused on
games so the tone has been set and like
tim said he's also said pay attention to
the pre-show
let's get into these predictions all the
way now man let's do it like what
what do we need let's get 10 let's get
to og man like what
do we need for this to be great what is
your predictions of this thing
well i think what we need honestly is uh
first of all the need to show halo and
needs to
show well yes i think we've discussed
that um
and it doesn't need to be glass
uh so listen so i think that we all want
fable right
so that has to be there um i think that
it's time
i remember last year when it wasn't
shown
a lot of people were upset yes a lot of
people were upset with phil
and i like when i when i we were talking
about one night
when when uh king was over there and and
he
the line was going i was talking to phil
at that time i had waved on the line
and uh at that point i was with phil for
a while
and like there were like people you know
wanted us chop
you know fable what happened to fable
and phil took a lot of heat for that
i think that we're gonna get fable i
think this the time is here so that's
two
we got halo fable um
now here's a big thing they're not gonna
show initiative supposedly i think that
they were originally
uh i think that if that's the case you
gotta show another
aaa whether it's a new ip uh whether
it's upstairs
i'm hoping that they show up i think if
they show up city and triple
a uh the rpg that's been long rumored
wrong talked about then
then you're at the point where you're at
now three big aaa's and then
the rest of the show you're gonna have
forza you're gonna have hellblade 2
which is you know
at the point where you're burying
hellblade 2
gameplay if that's what they're gonna
show uh that's a very good show listen
uh
listen i know people want them to show
everything right
um but i don't think that they're gonna
show everything just because i know how
phil is
i know how sony listen sony we all
agreed tony had the show
uh a great show whatever i gave you the
name i think i think some people
wanted more yeah but that's just the way
we are as gamers now if we go into the
predictions of that show
people were like oh yeah i mean
awards yes seven tr seven uh
you know deals with triple parts yes
square enix yes uh you know write it
down
it's a business um and i think that uh
that you have to
listen they have a lot of games you
might get you know you might get double
fine game but i think
it's the the the thing is
that for me it's a trifecta of triple
a's and i think halo's won
and i think fables two because it's been
long awaited you don't really have to
show that much and then i think
the new ip that everyone's wanting
uh if if obsidian can deliver that they
can show that ip
i think from there it's just it's just
gravy because you know you're gonna get
forza
you know you're gonna get um you know
hellblade ii
you know at that point you're at five
triple a's uh and you know that they
still got a lot left in the tank they
got initiative
they got an in exile who's building the
triple-a right
um now as far as the acquisition
yeah how much time tim because you're
talking about the triple
a's and i agree with you but how much
time do they spend on
uh stuff that we know about like
wasteland or grounded or
or their double or single a games within
their
aaa studios because we know they have
multiple teams do they spend any time on
those
very good question um i'm thinking if
what we want i think that we would get
minimal time on them
even though i mean i mean i think that i
think a lot of people want the big stuff
right so if they can deliver a you know
like you said if 10 minutes is a big
chunk so if they get 10 minutes of halo
5 minutes of fable five minutes of
obsidian then we're at 20 minutes then
you're gonna obviously have fours let's
say that
seven minutes because they're going to
come in and they're going to talk
they're going to talk about how uh
you know uh already some real reasons
what they're doing
they're recalling the engine whatever
like this yeah
they make it a real simulator um
you know and then and then like three
minutes of an interview like phil's
gonna talk you're at 30 minutes
you know at that point like you know
when we say it's an hour like if you
think about it
an hour's a lot of time if you're not
coming you don't have people walking in
on stage
and a lot of time without any
announcements they're
exactly typically seeing just games no
announcements that surprised me because
to be real
let's be real like the x-file joint
could have kind of jumped on this stage
and that would be yeah
a big announcement those are things they
normally do so i thought that was a big
deal continue to
yeah yeah and so i think they're gonna
really i think we're gonna head home
i'm hoping for a show that makes us all
happy because
last year um as you know i think i i had
a bad year i just just it was a bad e3
for me i went out drinking the night
before
you know it was a great thing we were
all there yeah but you know i mean
it was a great night and i loved being
with the fans but but the next day
was it really took a toll on me because
i'm older and whatever
there was no food there oh no
i mean tell them but you know the fact
is that um i was very grateful for
everything
though but i think that like i i wanted
like that like last year
it was like one of those feelings like i
left and i'm like you know what
i want to come back and i want them to
kick ass so i think this is that their
time
obviously we're we're not in the
position where we're all there we can
celebrate it together
but um i think that yeah i think i think
i think they could do it
i really do and i'm hoping they do it if
they don't do it listen i think that
people
there's going to be a large group of
people that are looking to critique the
show
and a large people are going to come out
and say oh it sucked you got no new ips
or whatever
whatever that narrative is but you know
what i think a lot of people are opening
their eyes to these people
saying you know about these narratives
that just keep coming up and propping up
against xbox
but then again like if you really want
to be about narratives then we could
shoot it right back at you about 30
frames per second
and you know 14 30p well all that stuff
and you know
i don't really want listen i i get it
that i'm that guy that pushes that
that button yeah i really just wish we
could all be cool
yeah but i see smoke
maybe it's just it is but i'm i'm not
gonna like get people when people are
gonna
you know it's not really console warring
i just think it's like
people like to just like you know go in
on xbox and get on
get on them on every little thing but
then like you know you talk about a
second
seven second loading time on the thing
although regardless there could be some
story to that
right but like the story is that ssd
ain't all that good
but it's like let him get his bars off
king don't be mad
don't don't be mad at me you might work
now
i'm boycotting no but i wish it wasn't
like that but
tim i like it like that all you twitter
dude i shut all of you up
all you little fake sony bosses did you
set up poor
gaming first you called us ceo yeah yeah
fake
fake ceos he's sitting there telling you
how to run the show
listen i'm so happy that you guys are
scared of my time y'all afraid of my
timeline
and i love it because i put you all in
the bushes y'all stood up
and one by one i cracked your full head
square open
so now you know you even got the one
general who can't say anything because
he don't have a pro so oops
oh my god
continue no but i honestly like i just
think we gotta hit it
they gotta really shut like if they show
let's just say they show fable they show
halo it looks good
and they show a completely new ip like
you said
it can even if it doesn't mean that they
didn't show fable which we haven't seen
in about seven years or a perfect dark
which has been
15 years old 15 years and it's just
we're using the same character and it's
called joanna dark but that's still not
a new yp according to these people
let's just say it's just uh they're
gonna have ever
ever ever while it's gonna be i heard
every while looking very good yeah
um so i hope we get some information i
think the game's overlooked you know a
lot of people
just say oh well cartoony and this and
that but that game looks beautiful
and that game i want i want to call it a
deep
you know yeah yeah you call this caller
to see yeah i think
like luke was asking you're going to see
maybe those games that are real
like usually if they're traditional they
do a five-minute reel of of games that
are coming
up these you know here here and there
but i don't think they're gonna do any
length
lengthy talks about them even though
grounded
to be honest i think it's a really good
game um
but uh you know if they have that and
they
and they get those three and they show
like five triple a's and your game play
up two of them
and you know that they got you know
initiative
aaa in the bank and then they got in
exile triple a in the bank
really you know as an xbox fan you got
to be happy because
there's gonna be a ton of information
that day like i said you're gonna have
to tune in at 11 o'clock
because you're gonna have a ton of
information and some of the information
like people said like
people like tim why would they wait
why wouldn't they just wait a week and
put this x cloud stuff there
and you know they got a point but the
thing is is that they have so much stuff
yes and that's including like the stuff
that they have in august
that you know in the next month and a
half this is going to be a really good
time
if you like that stuff and then when
these consoles come out
uh really with series x just you know
even the stuff that's going on on
twitter
i could tell you one thing they made
xbox they
waited for full our dna to they
waited okay that's why they were behind
because they waited
they wanted vrs and they wanted uh
machine learning built into it so they
could have machine learning for the
backwoods compatibility
they waited so they locked in their
hardware as the latest possible that
they can get to get the full feature set
i mean you're talking about a console
that's gonna that's gonna be amazing so
all it needs is a good show we all know
the console they're delivering on the
hardware all this is a good show
absolutely
i'm gonna be getting out of here but it
was a pleasure to be here
my dogs are here they're barking but um
uh really let's just hope that they do
it because if
i don't really want to be here and i'm
gonna be painful if they don't do it oh
i'm gonna be spooky if they don't
absolutely brother enjoy your day thank
you for pulling up tim
catch you later
remember that food is on you next time
thanks for thanks for showing up sorry i
missed half the podcast but thanks for
showing up
it's all good but i'm boycotting the
rest so i'll talk to you guys
let's get the answer never says oh yo
what
happened all right let's let's get these
give this a chat before you're right
first time being able to check live
thank you for the laughs and the facts
hashtag take the knees during date
thursday can't come soon enough let's go
oh and then we're at all yeah i think we
got jumped here
mm-hmm we got what else we got uh
okay then we have friend music two
dollars which
ps5 fans gonna be butt hurt with pc
releases
wow savage jean-marc louis with the two
dollar super chat
ainsley is the initiative working
multiple games
i'm getting my own super chats on your
show
your lord out here uh
so initiative from what i know is
working on multiple projects
um repeat that sentence because i had
this little part
of the contention with adam studio was
able to work on multiple projects
i didn't notice
i'm just so amazed i didn't know that
was possible continue
i don't even know the history of this
but it's still funny um
yeah all i know is that yes they're
working on multiple projects honestly
i'm pretty impressed with how um
close to the chest they've kept what
initiative is working on um they've kept
it locked down so
with the talent that studio has man
absolutely they're gonna be impressive
so that's all i know okay so we finished
up but we gotta go finish yeah we're
finished up okay so back to asia
man this is it big one the pressure's on
all the chips you know on the table like
what
what do you need man what do you need
and what's your predictions for this
show
yeah so funny enough i think tim touched
on a lot of it
um what i'm thinking so you as you guys
already said you covered a lot of it so
it's an hour
all games um you it one thing people
need to keep in check is right it can't
be triple a
for an hour right um you know just like
we saw with
with playstation you're probably going
to have this kind of entry
your exit and then you got the kind of
meet in the middle that's some other
kind of stuff you know i think you
definitely we already talked about halo
we already talked i think you're
definitely getting fable um
i think they end you know i didn't talk
about what i think they end on um i
actually don't think they end on halo i
actually think they end with the tease
for obsidian's rpg
but um touch one two because
that's the some people don't know right
obsidian's got three teams so they're
doing grounded it's a real small team
the mid team did out of worlds right
which i love i don't know about you guys
again
it's crazy it's crazy it's almost like
they could have multiple teams
um
but their obsidian has talent
talon for days right and their their top
tier team
is the team that was building the skyrim
you know
kind of next-gen fantasy rpg
um which is why what we've heard anyway
is why xbox bought them right
so anyway i think they're going to end
with a tease of that i think they
end with a tease of something new like
we were talking about new ip
right to basically say what the hell was
that you know we haven't seen that
before
it's on xbox gotta have it um
i don't know about perfect dark i the
argument you guys were talking about
with this hole it's not a new ip that's
such a stupid argument to me too yeah
listen to the fanboys
that's what the [ __ ] yeah oh go figure
right
um but i mean joanna dark
you know look at something like tomb
raider even um
or uh a loy right joanna dark has the
potential to be that kind of mass
we don't see mascots nowadays too much
right but that mascot style character
that you can create a triple a game
around in the vein of something like
splinter cell right
um and bring that as an exclusive
obviously with the talent you have in
xgs
um whether or not we see anything on
perfect dark this show i don't really
know i'm kind of 50 50 on it
okay but um you got hellblade too right
and then i think
uh we like i said tim touched on most of
these but i think that the middle some
of the other things you're going to get
are going to sobs point about uh a and
double a
stuff but stuff that we haven't seen or
we've been waiting to see a good example
for me would be cuphead's expansion
um you know we've been waiting on this
last course for a while cuphead
has a it has a big audience man it
really does
and so i think you start to see um some
some things like that in the middle of
the show kind of you know
interspersed right so anyway i think the
big kind of end caps we were talking
about like this the bookshelf you know
if you're end capping you've got halo
somewhere in there you know
like i said i honestly don't think it
matters because halo is going to be
it'll take over the focal point when
it's on no no you've got fable there
somewhere beginning end i think you get
obsidian rpg you've got hellblade
um probably see forza i would expect
right although we're hearing that fours
is actually not going to launch right
we're here
it's going to be 2021. so i don't know
if forza would actually be there or not
and everyone the
initiative game uh a tease from
initiative has gone back and forth as
well now i was in the no
camp because that's what we were hearing
until the matt booty interview last week
when he said i don't want to say too
much because we've got our showcase next
week
when he was talking about initiative so
now now i don't know again
back in play his initiative yeah exactly
exactly so
i don't really know but i think like i
said i think tim kind of hit it you're
gonna you're gonna have your you've got
your pillar
triple a franchises right um which we've
talked about but then i think you're
gonna see things like the cuphead piece
um and some other kind of double a uh
stuff interspersed the one thing
i don't think we're gonna see but i'm
really curious about and i keep telling
people about this is keep an eye on
compulsion
um compulsion is a studio that is going
to surprise people
i'm telling you about in my bag
because their next project is from what
we know about it
is um horror-esque not a horror game but
dark right um and if you think about the
potential for that type of market with
the talent that compulsion has and has
added
um compulsion's gonna surprise some
people so i i'm just excited i always
talk about compulsion and what they're
gonna do next but keep an eye for them
absolutely we had the one
that's where i'm at yeah we've had them
in the realm we were told yeah
definitely new ip
possibly yeah possibly that realm over
this you know third person possibly get
that during going but let's get the
ghost man i need i need the young gunner
young guys so look young young
he's the old guy
so a lot of predictions but a lot of
them based on logic and then there's
always that that hype side so you've got
like two camps of thought right there
right
um i think you get the sizzle reel early
uh to aaron greenberg's point
appropriate expectations
where we are are gonna see games games
games but they got a system to sell
so you sizzle reel the games that are
already out at some point
you show gears 5 you show the stuff
that's already here
and ori and what the series x will do to
those games because visually
they've already got some massively
powerful visual powerhouses on this
system
right series x will make those look
better they just will
right um and so you sizzle reel that
stuff
i think you're gonna have some aaa
bangers in there
uh you got your fables you'll probably
have a perfect dark your hellblade too
but you have to foot off the pedal
at some point that's what ains was
saying and whatnot and
king i don't know if you were joking or
not but when you talk about call of duty
that's the exact game you show after a
big
triple a spot yes
and so you you see we i think we see
fable i think you see some perfect dark
uh you get extensive halo you
you see games that are one to three
years out we talk about
phil holding stuff back yes you do hold
stuff back
don't make us look past three years you
got 15 studios
that probably have multiple teams
playing inside
i mean like we already know that what is
it uh ninja theory is working on three
things project insight mara
and hellblade so show your one to three
year vision
why we need to buy into xbox now why we
can stick with xbox
later we already that's the key there we
know we're gonna be here for one to
three years and their services are going
to deliver it
on whatever platform you get it's as
simple as that um
i think you're going to see some
cyberpunk talk i
will say that they have not done a good
enough job
celebrating rare's legacy where replay
was
the goat when it came out a lot of pla a
lot of ip in there
but that was and that was what piloted
backward compatibility triggers which is
neat
um but i mean king and i played it
together
battletoads yes stealth drop on the day
yeah if
you know stealth drop on the day they
need a new banjo
they need a new banjo crazy that rare
ghetto babes banjo i don't i don't want
to hear anyone saying we don't need
banjo
we can bring banjo sea of thieves
is a great game rare really you would do
it so well go
do it so well dude
stick with me god because like what we
talked about with the pc talk right like
they stuck with stuff that that could
have failed master chief collection was
abysmal
sea of thieves did not launch well they
turned those properties around
yes yes rare's primary team is sea of
thieves but
new banjo maybe are they consulting
they've got a lot of rare ip
there's a lot of places to go and so
that's what i want to see them do and
i'm looking at my notes
we know that netherrealm is has got a
lot going on right now and when the wb
att stuff complicates it we also know
that netherrealm is making a game that's
not a fighting game
rules out killer instinct if they're
acquired you know for the people that
are that are
hot pie in the sky heather is making
something that's not a fighting game
do we see a splinter cell title we know
that ubisoft forward has a second
show in coming up in a few months do
they put it on xbox stage and say we'll
see you in august
do they do that for wb stuff batman do
they do that for splinter cell
and i'm just i'm i'm throwing these out
there because
you have to have tempered expectations
the stuff we know right the stuff we
think we know
fable perfect dark and then you put pie
in the sky stuff for excitement
register where you are on your on your
your charts
and acknowledge some stuff's not
realistic they're not going to come out
and say we bought wb
deals done because that's that's fresh
but if they could tease something
there's no reason to say batman wasn't
going to be shown on their on their
stage
or splinter cell wasn't going to be
shown so balance that and the big
the big uh wild card and all of this and
the reason it fluctuates so much
is is coveted 19. it's changed every
plan and
everybody yeah gets a pass everybody
gets a pass things have changed we don't
know the stuff i'm doing we're doing
reflection
he did phil gets it
he gets it he's he's a businessman he's
a gamer that's a businessman no doubt he
doesn't be my best friend
he's got to sell me games and that's how
you do it one to three years lots of
stuff
and then my fun one i really think halo
is going to show up on
november saturday november 7th 11 7 117
you see the boss i like that i like that
117 with the connect
okay oh i see you i see you ghost y'all
got it all right oh what what real quick
one thing i forgot to mention is third
party right everyone
it's not a it's an xbox game showcase
xbox game
studios true showcase so they have the
marketing deals keep in mind for eldon
ring
cyberpunk ac valhalla and star wars
squadrons
they have the marking deals for all four
of those big games so good point
very good point be aware of that good
point good point addict
is your time you've been very patient
i'm still in my boycotting
i need you bro i need you this is very
important to you you're very passionate
about
i can talk now yeah i can talk now
everyone else got their bars off
no i didn't get my balls off you know
i'm barry bones you know set it up tee
it up for me i'll put the glue over this
addict's world now
addict this is very important to you
king i want you to get your bars off nah
brother you don't get i don't know i
don't know
you can't switch that i want you to
position the hitters you know
understand alex rodriguez go first
what do you do man this is the big one
what do you mean
yeah you showed me a good representation
of halo you showed me fable i'd really
appreciate it banjo was there i love
banjo
i think i think the only people that i
would say would be making that
i feel like double fine might make that
game i don't know why but
i feel like double fight could actually
make a banjo because i don't think ray
are making it
like not even remotely i think writers
making that i agree
i don't think the initiative's going to
be there okay i don't think that's
we're going to see much we'll see
something related to hellblade but i
don't think it's going to be a lot
because they showed that at the launch
and i think that we're
i think that if they end with anything
it's neither going to be fable or
obsidian's new iep
okay okay okay no doubt so that's that's
the main thing though like i know we
talked with you with the significance of
of fable and halo right so
for you and the success you need
both can we we had that little thing
like can one be good and the other one
be
average or whatever like where you at
with them no they both have to be good
they have to be
like i'm at this point where it's just
like it's
it's show up or go home i'm not i'm not
to the mindset that a lot of people have
like my i'm not tempering my
expectations i'm not doing none of that
like
it's neither you blow me away you blow
my socks off
or you could go home can i can i jump in
i'm
with addict on that i don't know you get
your bars off there go go get your bars
off man i
i agree because i i do speak to the idea
of tempered expectations
similarly this is xbox's moment
they've they they had the metric era
and spencer's been building for this
they need to bring it
and that is that is not a a fanboy
mindset
they need to bring it because they've
had
they've had years where it was slow they
had games that we liked but or some
people liked some people didn't
they've not had the god of wars they
haven't had the last of us they haven't
had ghosts
where these are like this game of the
year right now is how good how good how
good i would
really you can leave ghosts out it's
crazy
it's on to be honest
if you're not going to be excited about
this particular event
what else should you be excited about
like
it's at the point where like this is it
like
there's no e3 after this like there's
none of that like this this is it
and they put that pressure on themselves
and i think they're ready for it
they put the pressure on themselves and
they are ready for it they know
these are diff this is a different
microsoft than five six seven years ago
their ears to the ground they get it and
if you don't think that
they're not aware of the memes of keeley
and the controller
wear the refrigerator aware that
nintendo might do a direct tomorrow
if you don't think they know this and
they're still gunning for it they could
have backed out pulled an amazon and a
stadia
months years ago they didn't they
doubled down
this is their moment so i wanted to jump
in and support you on that idea
i think we all agree all right i think
that i think we all agree that they have
to show big
yes i i don't think this is one of those
things where you know
obviously they can hold some things back
and when i say some i mean very nun
i think that's just one of those things
it's like look like there's a huge
audience
you know a lot of people like to take
away from the the narrative to these
influencers and stuff that's one of the
reasons they lost this generation
because it was the price difference
because every influencer
hated their guts and you know you could
say what you want the angry joes the
the big influences they got they got a
massive audience and when you lose them
you lose their fans right when you lose
their fans
well that's because of the messaging it
was everything it was just like look
like they had
there's very few brands that could have
survived what happened in two thousand
dollars that is a fact
very few the fact that they they got hit
from every corner it reminds me of like
the 300 scene where they knew they were
done
and they barely like they had to send
their survivors man
they're like look we did you gotta leave
go sell our store
this is the time to come out man like
you know i don't want to hear no
we're gonna show fable next year not
none of that none of that stuff
it's like you show it now because we
first off it's like the one of the worst
kept secrets
you might as well show it right i i just
i need them to show up and to hit run i
need them to give cognito his little
one-and-done thing just what
i i i i need i need fable to look
great it can't look good it needs to
look great
i need fable to be first and not last
i need i need fable to come out there
they don't have to show me gameplay
unfavorable because i do think that
might be a little unrealistic i would
like a
you know a little could you be a
reasonable look at you
the thing i i i would like for them to
show me like
you know a snippet of like a story
trailer that that might show what the
the world is going to look like
right they need to show hell blade they
need to question
are you cool being that you're the
fabled connoisseur are you cool with a
vertical slice
yes i would be okay with vertical slice
as long as it is actually representative
in the game
okay okay well how the gameplay lords
are very upset they're like game play
game played
you don't get no game i'll make sure
i would like
i would like for obsidian's game to to
shine now i do think obsidian game needs
a vertical slice because we need to see
what form of gameplay that they're going
to do
i don't want to see nothing but like
cgi's
like i'm a very against that now there
are a couple exceptions you know
obsidian and fables
are the only ones i've given an
exception to if compulsions there it
needs to have gameplay
gotcha hellblade needs to have gameplay
fair enough it needs to have game
gameplay and just show another cgi
cutscene
l because it's like you shouldn't showed
up at all without blades
uh
because they put it that way like this
is literally the event you sell your
next brand with like
this isn't just some this isn't like an
e3 2015
like this is it like no more wait till
next year no more wait till next e3 yeah
i don't want to wait till next week
this is it like i know people say
already telling me well that's in the
august don't know
i don't care about the august event
we're gonna be live that's i feel you
bro
and they haven't had this much will in
like eight nine years at this point
because
because of the services smart delivery x
cloud game best they've got
the momentum they could either trip and
fall right
or they could plow through the wall and
show everybody why they are
go no doubt solve i need you to get
these super chat then you jump in
uh we got dan rodriguez just to find out
what's in the chat how to step away for
a bit
is ain't still babbling on about halo
yeah
stupid super chat provided by sg and
mariano
hashtag
oh my god the disrespect
it's just it's gonna be a three-person
show next week
xbox will deliver a hot show with
multiple great games for everyone to get
hyped about
that is the hope um i think we're good
nope will we
have to find out super chat attic is
still cancelled
wow then we have uh mariano pompa with
the
forty dollar super chat
shout out to the lord will me for
helping me save money thank you iop
seasoned gaming gaming beyond the box
and others
keep us informed and having fun through
these crazy times appreciate what all of
you guys do
let's go go don't forget the xbox
expansion pass
except it goes throw that up here that's
fine buddy audiobook
that on itunes right now you know what
i'm saying but um yeah we got
we caught up with everything we got we
got neal mental with the fight out chat
no
debt no no deadbolt you cut it out
um then we got r b with the two dollar
super chat
no more banjo to the bushes with the
kitty game hold on our rmb we're going
to talk for a second
like i don't understand this mentality
that people are against
banjo get them i don't get that like
just because you don't like it don't
mean other people ain't gonna like it
like
i don't care about whatever the
initiative is making outside it's a
as it is do you see me i want you know
what cardinal i want them to
dismantle all of the initiative i don't
care about their games
gamers are inherently selfish that's
just what it is man you know like look
look man
like at the end of the day if it's not
if it's not what you want
just don't watch the channel don't watch
the trailer
don't buy the game hopefully phil does
not say that on stage
continue look what happened when they
announced
banjo just being a character in smash
brothers
shout out to adam getting the soda down
man chicken them
well first off i wasn't telling phil
spencer to say that
i was like well i hope that ain't the
marketing all right you want to get
us off yeah we have phil eagle to find
out xbox games are diverse
i have a feeling most of you triple a
enthusiasts will be upset because it's
not a triple h show
it's an xbox game just my opinion i do
think that is realistic to say that
i would say that we know what the
triple-a is going to be pretty much the
fables the halo the obsidian game
don't expect every game to be a triple-a
title right no not at all not at all but
it's like cox says i think just that one
hashtag just just add to the pillars and
we have a
gamer's plate just fight all the super
chat after thursday everyone will know
why
there is no power greater than x hashtag
[ __ ]
x no doubt no doubt soft get your bars
off man this is the big one man what do
you need polarizing
as like i said i think in the in the
pre-show we're going to get a lot of the
smaller stuff that you maybe don't want
to stuff into the uh the main show i
think gears tactics get an announcer
yeah i think i think that's that's where
you say gears tactics coming to console
uh this day and date whatever i think
you may be shadow drop
battle toads um and give it a nice
chunk of time in the pre-show same thing
i've been waiting for 12 minutes forever
i would love to see that game shadow
drop
yeah i love that game um and then beyond
that
and the show proper i'm gonna be honest
man i think even if we get a tease
from every single one of their 15
studios
we get a tease i think this is when it
comes to it's time to show
to be honest with you he's not wrong
like i do
think you're going to see 80 percent of
their studios this thursday
night and that's box games that's fine
by me but again
but the thing is is the event in may
they sh they told this is that studio
pretty much like that
will you go here to to see our first
party stuff that's what ian greenberg
said so yeah like
so i'm assuming at the very least the
majority is going to be their stuff the
focus is going to be their stuff right
the third party stuff ains mentioned i
absolutely agree you need to you need to
spotlight that stuff right
interspersed with i think and again if
you talk about an hour
and like like tim that said like it's an
hour without transitions it's not it's
just it's a straight up
hour that's pre-recorded of information
that you know you need to fill that up
so to me
you just tease whatever don't be afraid
to tease something that's four years out
okay i don't care about that like
playstation gets away with it all the
time
show me that you have confidence and
what you what's coming down pipeline
that you're not afraid to show it years
out i feel that
so when it comes to what's coming like
obviously obsidian whatever obsidian's
big aaa thing is besides the sequel to
the outer worlds
i think it has to be spotlighted um the
initiative stuff whatever multiple stuff
they're working on
give me a tease of everything and maybe
a little bit more of what's
closest in the pipeline right um in
exile again
this this is this is a studio that's
accustomed to being small
and working on small crpg type games
spotlight them in a way that shows what
what whatever new they're doing is
is sort of a little bit of a departure
from them in terms of size and scope
right
get us excited about that when it comes
to rare uh i think ever wild
is being under it's not being looked at
the way it should be like anything
because of the way it looks as a
cartoony game people dismiss it
immediately but if you have if you
create a world that's as engaging as a
breath of the wild
people are gonna look at your game like
people are going to look at your game
the same way we looked at that game
during the playstation conference um now
i forget what it's called
um it's i i think they need to give us
that sort of energy for everworld
games except for those three games all
they talked about was uh
gran turismo alloy oh oh no four games
gran turismo
mo alloy and uh miles and ratchet and
clay
right and that was and everything
exactly buck snacks becomes a meme and
then the smaller stuff that
you when you see it you're like oh wow
that's cool why didn't they give us more
on that right
i didn't see that i'm gonna tell you
right now i didn't see nothing i didn't
see
anything else no i didn't see anything
else that was there because they don't
have a
game pass type of situation i'm not
spending no money
on something somebody's passion project
god bless good luck
i'm not supporting somebody's passion
like kings just say what all of us are
thinking like let's be real when those
were going on did you think within one
second
you know what that looks good let me buy
them rolling no one said
no well what did we say what did we say
those games was gonna happen with those
games on the playstation platform is you
know what's gonna happen
those games are gonna eventually come to
xbox and day and day on game pass that's
gonna happen
but those games on the playstation
platform they're going to big them up
until
their their triple a's are ready and
then they're going to throw them off to
the side
they're going to beat them up for no
reason because they don't buy games
like you look at turn 10 and playground
obviously playground
i to me if you were going to launch a
system with a
with a forza game i think i think
horizon is the better look because it
it's more of a it's not a simulation
game it doesn't isolate sort of the
time schedules right we just had four
right horizon four so it doesn't make
sense that they would be there
motorsport
if motorsport is a thing now i hope that
they
evolve that formula from what it usually
is because i i mean how many
times are you going to see the
nurburgring like re remade like
i i would like to i would like the
formula to be evolved and maybe
do something with it that allows more
players to be interested in it in a way
that they are with horizon
as opposed to like like a simulation
game is a straight-up racing game
whereas horizon is a
it's a driving game it's about the scene
the scenarios it's about how pretty the
game looks
um then your compulsion i agree with
aims completely compulsion has the
ability
to step into that sort of
uh a studio that can make a bio a
bioshock type game
right they have the storytelling chops
for it it's a matter of putting the
proper game around it because
as we saw we happy few what we expected
from that game in the beginning wasn't
what we got right we got
kind of like a survival type game and
good story though
the story around it was good but if you
didn't if you didn't want to deal with
the gameplay you never get stuck around
that i call it diamond in the rough it's
pretty rough around the edges absolutely
but i think what they can do
storytelling wise is very very
interesting i'm super interested to see
what they do
mo yang obviously you have minecraft
dungeons and you have
we're gonna see minecraft ray traced and
all that stuff on the on the on the
series x and that's someone keeps
mentioning is there's something wrong
with my mic
like good you're good now you're gonna
know that someone just i saw it
we did it he's fine he's fine i think
he's joking he's just joking with you we
just jump
so i mean again mo yang is going to keep
doing their thing
double fine is interesting because again
i would love to see banjo come back
and uh a banjo by double fine
because double fines they said their
comedic chops
are on another level so if you add that
to banjo and again
to me for banjo coming back it has to be
a game that is made on par with the
mario games like
that is a level of i'm asking a lot but
if we go back if we go back really banjo
kazooie was
it came out after super mario 64
obviously it's a better game it's a
better game
it's a better game
so to me it it can be done it just you
just need to put that work in there you
need to put that team there
that that has those chops um ninja
theory obviously i don't think we see
anything from project mara i definitely
want to see hellblade
game play i think we need to see that
you like alex said like if you come with
another trailer
show me the game show me the game and
then on dead labs man like i was talking
i don't know if they're ready but again
tease me with with this
this this super in in-depth
you know i think apocalyptic rpg that
you've been i think people
i think people are sleeping on commotion
like i really do
oh no i see that's when i was on my
boycott face so right now i'm good
thank you for that listening
voice and ears continue i told you i was
in the chat i was a viewer at that time
yeah right now i'm a podcast member
and i think people are sleeping on pizza
uh
i wasn't eating pizza thank you
it's a strawberry shortcake
i ran i pretty much ran down every
studio um i i think
it's time to tease everything i don't
care if it's four years out
tease it let me let me know let me know
because it
appreciates
you see the thing is like king king i
just have one thing to say it's like
look like
at the end of the day i understand they
they're most likely not going to do that
they are going to leave a couple of
studios probably the initiative
and you know still have a second i think
i think exile's second game they're
definitely going to uh keep that close
to the chest but
to me it's just like look like if you
look at it from perspective
they have more to prove than they that
than they've ever
absolutely it and i and i personally
feel like you know
that's what sony does it clearly it's
working good for them just shooting they
load five six years in advance but
but xbox does not have the pedigree
of ip right now that sony has the
goodwill of the gamer and that's that's
a that's not just a truism
and the further out they go they risk
another
crackdown three state of decay quantum
break situation
that's the only danger of going so far
out and expectations
mounting and you're aware of it and that
i understand that but when you look at
when you look at sony's uh catalog right
they announce games
four or five years out they do they give
you a reason to buy it instead
99 of the time those games come out
right
you have to have the same confidence in
in your studios you have to have that
same confidence in what you're bringing
to the table
if you don't it says something
right it says something to somebody like
me who pays attention to that stuff i'm
like well
i agree but they put out last guardian
they put out that kill strain game and
then they closed a bunch of studios
but nobody remembers it because of the
the the god of wars and the last one the
thing is is
they need those games like the problem
with sony and microsoft right now the
difference is
microsoft's only doing the negative
stuff for the most part
sony's actually putting out a lot more
of the positive games as jen
like if microsoft would have had one
game like on the quality of
of go shima last of us two i think it
would be a lot easier on them but the
problem is they're not doing that
so not only do you see stuff getting
shut down you see games getting canceled
you're not seeing like the shift in
balance basically what you're saying
it is allowed that that good will you
know so
they're like look this is how people see
the oh that's cute they they close all
these studios on sony down
apparently it's not bothering that much
they just released ghosts of kashima
they just released last of us too
they're still having extremely quality
games and i think that's the issue
that people have right now and that's
and that's you have to convince
the consumer why why am i coming to xbox
why am i coming to xbox because
especially because of the last
generation right right and
exactly especially because the last
generation so you have to me you just
have to
you drop everything you have to show
everything and to some extent i'm not
saying give me game play for a game just
five years out
i'm telling you give me give me a logo
and tell me that it's coming with that
psg
you keep that in the oven before you
give me a png
metroid i
see gameplay and then i was like crack
down three we saw that concept no no no
no no no so i i
i see what you're saying the thing about
the thing about that ghost is like
i honestly think at that time
all of microsoft was trying to be too
much like oh let's make this
crackdown let's do these but the thing
is
they still marketed the way they did
right
crackdown's campaign was great i loved
it it's just that multiplayer man yeah i
think a crackdown
they were put between a rock and a hard
place right
right if you would have put a lot more
work in the in the campaign you would
have uh you know
if you would have filled out those spots
that needed to be filled out
and you just took that same world you
made it to the multiplayer and let them
walk around blowing stuff up like in gta
5.
i think it would have worked out great
for them like you know but the fact is
is they went out and they jumped out the
window yo we got a fully destructible
world
behind that the technology i've heard
changed right
about it gotta
phil did mention strong focus on
japanese studio ips
can you say marketing rights for new
japanese games could be
i don't i don't think they're gonna have
a whole focus on marketing right games i
think that
if you see a huge focus on third party
it's gonna be because
some of these games are going to have
some kind of relationship with game pass
like you you might see like new game
play on hog games but i think you're
going to see more war premieres than
just games that's already been announced
next super chat they have viper with the
five dollar super chat
porter rock 77 out here on twitter
trying to say microsoft is going to
force game pass on players
to be able to play online that pony is
trying to
force the tcl away from him and force a
pro on them
i may be the only person to feel this
way but i really want to see in exile's
next game i think no we're all excited
for that
no doubt beater 81 27 500 why does
microsoft keep
dumping for jeff they keep swooning
but he's going to keep giving that
nookie to sony what
wow savage
is it it's that feeling that jeff like
sometimes when it comes to xbox stuff he
just doesn't look like he's excited like
he didn't look like he was excited with
that controller either
yeah that was that was suspect man that
was really successful
he was forced to go to school
then we got a gotham guy with the follow
superchat with having the most powerful
console there's no excuse for microsoft
to disappoint us
again i say release the hounds yes sir
everything
you know what king you know what that
controller showed me one thing
breathalyzer people don't like the way
you drunk people don't even need to buy
a weapon no more man that thing's big
enough to
no force drama any situation now okay
let's let's not keep
it let's just keep going i like the
controller let's just
let's stop everybody think i'm bashing
it too big
i like her no i got big hands i love
that controller thank you so much
it was bulky i have to i had to get it
in my hand before i really
talked about but i've always hated the
playstation control and it's always been
a barrier
you know maybe because it's being bigger
like it'll feel like my thumbs don't
touch
right because right now your joints is
like rubbing each other
yeah definitely pause yeah
shout out to them having a series in it
and uh
you with the breathalyzer right there it
will call the police on you
so what you need for this show man come
on all right so
all right first they already uh it
doesn't really matter what he needs man
because he go
king is the ultimate spinner well guys
that's what the show is king will make
you sound lit
can i get my parts off please
yeah so um first of all shout out to
them for
um doing what i felt that they should do
if their games are going to be in 60
frames per second please show the show
in 60 frames per second
thank you um there was no reason for
sony to show their show on
60 francs and none of the games was
doing it okay so
now let's get to what my expectations
are
and what i see i don't uh hold back any
expectations
and this is not going off of uh anything
that was in my dms or anything that
people
you know talk to me about on the side um
because truly
right about now i'm going off of past
history
right they have always shown the most
games on stage
they have always shown the most world
exclusive we learn
different lingo through microsoft world
premier
world premiere like we're like what
console launch exclusive
so you know he learned different terms
legalities through microphone
and it's fantastic but they also show
you the most games
and you know their sizzle reels really
be sizzle reels of 130 something games
while other people are showing like
three games and then looping it in the
sizzle reel
um shots all right so you're gonna have
in in the middle of the show i believe
you're gonna have four
aaa games okay four because that's the
way that you hold the uh um
a show up i'll show up this magnitude if
if it's going to be
e3 esque it's going to be of this
magnitude
right so okay so four games
we already know that it's going to be uh
halo fable um
i i'm i'm not going to stay gears as not
as one of those
uh four games because the other two
needs to be triple a titles coming that
we don't know about
i'm liking this right they have to be
something that we're like oh
well look yeah who's working on that
that's what it has to be
right and you booked that let me ask you
one question real quick king would you
consider like
fable one of those games considering we
might know about that but the
the masses of people that don't keep up
with the twitter critics they don't know
stuff like that
if you didn't just jump in right now
just about to tell you you booking them
with halo and
um fable fable like i said starts off
the show
halo ends the show and that's how it's
supposed to be and that's how it's going
to be
um but in in the middle you give those
two games but you have to
break you want to do a bend the knee on
what they open this up with
i don't think you need to bend any knees
because your knees so do you want to do
it
literally your knees is back here
man what is the bending knee about
addiction
why don't you love this diversion you
don't want to do this bend the knee i
want you to just
earn your knees just say yes or no
you're just selling credit knees
yes or no are you going to bend the knee
okay then there you go there you go you
got your answer now continue
sit down and be
not working with quiet credit knees we
want actual needs i got your actual
needs man
at the end of the year you're gonna have
no need so that's fine continue
king thank you i do appreciate all this
interrupts per second it's very high
let's get through right so like
i said uh you have fable in the
beginning you have halo at the end you
have the two games that we don't know
about this triple a titles
that's bracketed right and bracketed
those are the ones that we don't know so
i'm not saying that um
you know hellblade isn't a triple a
title but that game is in the middle
right right and it's not those out of
those two games that we're
we don't know what they are so when
you see what what they're going to bring
across they're going to bring across
diversity
right across all genres right microsoft
needs to have a ton of games going
inside game pass
so when sony was doing their show and
they showed you games
that you was like curious right
i know every every game that they showed
on a screen
is making their way into game pass
and they did this and i saw it with um
devil may cry
5. so i get this makes me watch the show
differently than i will watch any other
show right
you won't have any conversation of
hardware you won't have any conversation
of services
you won't have any conversation of
anything that people
may be looking for all right people have
none of that's in there
yeah that'd probably be in the pre-game
and that
probably be well most likely will be in
august
now i don't go with the philosophy that
a lot of people
are going with uh saying that they gotta
unload the bank
um because there is a show in august
[Music]
i heard on good authority uh-oh
exclusive
world premiere what we're doing
with all those stupid-ass transitions
excuse me but all the stupid transitions
that they did in that playstation show
you look three games that i knew that
was supposed to be there and from what i
had those three games is going to be
shown in august okay all right so you
want to hold something back
focus if if at this point in time
you craft the whole show microsoft has
enough stuff to craft a whole nother
show they did it
hey they did that crafting of the show
and made with third-party support games
right the people was all upset about i
don't know why all those games i'll be
playing
so now you have the july show which has
the aaa titles which going to have some
third-party stuff in there
some deals that they have to
contractually show on their face the
screen
which i don't want to see cyberpunk
again but they're going to show it again
i don't see assassin's creed but they're
going to show it again because they are
obligated to show these games in a good
light on their stage because they have
these contracts with them
right we will see this stuff but we want
to see the games that they don't
that we don't know about right so we're
going to be two games from their studios
that we don't know about that's going to
be uh
aaa titles right honestly psychonauts 2.
you're going to see that in there you're
going to see a lot of games there's a
lot of stuff that you're going to see
and just to bracket it off yeah start it
off with fable you end it off with halo
and you end it off with a cliffhanger of
halo you start off with the trailer
whatever you know
uh the vertical slice the trailer that
you don't show the whole thing
you show the 10 minutes of game play
and lead up to a scene with somebody
like turning around the corner some
shock value something
that is in the game that makes you go
what though yeah aatrox
with lock's helmet right something
but they they do something of that
nature
and leave it off at that and they tell
you see you and
[Music]
feeling um but but at the same time
right now go
download the playable beta oh
multiplayer beta of halo infinite
that is generational this is the reason
why
you have the ability to be transparent
with your consumers and saying that
you're not going to be left behind if
you got a regular xbox you have a x
go play right now like that might be at
30 frames but you can still play
go play right now but when you get a
series x is going to be exponentially
better
but you can join in the fun right now
give us your feedback tell us what we
what what you think about it
um same thing that goat said i believe
that they uh
drop battle toes battle because
everybody's looking where's battle toes
we have battle toes for some people that
don't want to see battle talk
everybody keeps asking for it right
gamepad it drops and as far as
banjo-kazooie
i am a huge fan of it i am a huge fan of
that world i'm a huge
i don't really like the way but
i understood why they did it and they
kept it going
so i think they're going to expand on
the universe who's to say
who's to say and everybody keeps trying
to pass the game
on from rare who's to say since
uh sea of thieves isn't as profitable
and as uh played by millions that is
there's millions
millions like i said
and that's how i got other knees um
who's to say that they don't have a
skeleton at that time the game wasn't
successful
at the time i put it it was though and
it was pretty wrong it wasn't serious
i need you to jump out of my segment
i'm gonna need you to stop saying uh
crazy stuff for
500 please pick you up
anyway who's to say they don't have a
skeleton crew running that part right
there
you just make sure everything is good
you know tightening up because it
doesn't have no
super dlc coming right now so let's just
keep that tight enough who's to say they
wasn't secretly working
on a bonjour kazooie game of the
magnitude that a series x
needs it's possible it's possible let me
let me jump in if you got your boss up
because i got it
i'm done look look you're gonna jump
back in the second
the ipsi but look man you know can't
take a a shot at me king and then expect
me not to say something just saying you
know how do we do it
i know how you play listen let's let's
get to it man this is the big one
this is it um i would solve this this
there's no more to tomorrow yeah i don't
want here wait till august
we shot the half of the shotgun and
we're saving this one for the
listen it's like dylan said it's time to
start i'm gonna start what he says time
to start shooting incognito that's where
i'm at
that's where i'm at i'm no no more this
way and ain't no tempering expectations
here
i'm expecting a lot i'm expecting a lot
you this is the generation
you lost the generation you shouldn't
have lost last year
in my opinion with bonehead marketing
and messaging
and you were more expensive right
everything you have done to this point
has been to turn around a narrative
that let's be real i think was king has
said it or some said it
most people would not have survived the
way
they started the gen with the xbox one
it it was
it's a tremendous turnaround for them to
still be here and be successful so i
gotta give credit to that
however you've got to win a whole set of
gamers
that left you from the 360 right and
went to the playstation 4. so the first
thing we know what the price we know
with the power we see what the
potential like king said the two-pronged
attack you know whether it be
lockhart and then in series x we're
seeing with the services we're seeing
with all access right
we're seeing this multi-faceted approach
to get
a larger group of gamers right which
sounds great now the key is this
this is the game's time the biggest meme
like king says
xbox has no games that's the me they pay
attention
phil is outside he's been listening to
all these
narratives that everyone has thrown in
front of him and into king's point
he's done a masterful job of trying to
attack each one
this is the big one though so they gotta
deliver i'm with um
solving the sense that i want to see
what composure's doing like
ain't just saying i want to see a lot of
these studios
that have been kind of what's coalition
doing you know i'm saying like
just again maybe do we get full gameplay
from a lot of these things i don't know
but it would be cool to have some
idea of the future and that is what sony
does well they give their base hope
so even if you don't have it right now
they know horizon zero two is carbon
dawn two color
right they they know that aren't your
questions just real quick let's get to
it let's get to it
they give you hope because they have
nothing now right
okay is is that is that the case is that
the case selling dreams
um i feel where you actually because you
have nothing to offer at the moment
that's like telling a girl you promise
her to give her a ring next year when
your finances fixes
opposed to the dude that has his
finances fixed right now
but on most people but are most people
that aren't us buying a new xbox
for what's out now right that's the
question and
and that's that's the promise that sony
always gives you right
that's that's the promise that they give
you and believe it you know
believe in it or not believe in how you
know believing how they go about
their business or not right it works it
works
that's how i look at it i kick i know
what you're saying to the letter of the
lord you're like
a lot of some of it is smokescreen some
of these games don't come four or five
years later
but the end of the day they've earned
the cachet that when they do
drop those tend to be bangers so people
are going to have
an extra set of loyalty to that to that
hope
it's microsoft's job now to convince
convincing look this is what we got
besides the core stuff that you know
about here's this other stuff
and here's why we bought all these
studios this is what people are cooking
up
right to give that sense of hope to
invest in the brand you know what i'm
saying
so that that's where i'm at with it i'm
weird addict in a sense man
he needs fable we need fable i would
love fable
you don't say it's a pillar franchise
for them they they need to kind of
get that going i hear you if they don't
show fable
like i'm automatically done we're like
yeah
yeah now the only way i'm okay with
fable not being shown
is if halo looks spectacular right
but but it oh i'm telling you man you
you guys
do you if you if they don't show fable
and you really want to see someone go
off right come come to iopino
this silencing addict that they've done
this week that ain't happening next week
everybody and i i i boy i hope you get
it man i really
you've been waiting a long time and look
the last i'll keep it simple man look
as i told a kid like phil
is outside he's outside this is a
the equivalent to the way i look at it
is if someone's been bullied
for a long time right and now every time
you see he can't
wait to talk about them and what you
know how he's more confident
about this show than their show and he
he's been throwing out jazz he paid
attention it's been subliminals in
every little thing this is a person to
me when i look at them
that he's extremely confident he's
extremely
excited about what he's going to show so
now the issue just comes down to
execution right
you've got to land the plane you've
talked it you've got to land it
i think it's going to be i think they've
learned a lot from the mistakes and i
think now it's just going next-gen is
going to be super competitive
i think they're ready i think i think
they're going to deliver i honestly do i
mean i i don't see
this level of talking you know
someone said in the comment section if
matt if alex sees no
fable he'll get so worked up he'll shave
his beard
listen man that that's just what i got
man it's gonna be a fun one
i'm tuning in uh you know on thursday
we're tuned into the pre-show you know
lords are gonna be there
i can't wait y'all this is it's gonna be
a fun one man we definitely tuned into
the reaction we're we're definitely
gonna be reacting to the game
to the event all right let's get out of
here it's super long show y'all
um all right so paul with the pressure
of the xbox games
showcase approaching which of these
games do you feel should start with the
opening presentation
of the show choices are hey i feel like
you changed that in the middle of the
whole no
it was cooking it was good hey fable
prove it exists and it is reborn
b brand new ip proof xbox game studio
has been cooking up quality
c halo infinite set the tone
boot on the neck and d i don't care it
best not be grounded or see a thief
so salute to the lord it will go up on
twitter let's get a big
shout out for the marathon my boys lord
tim gong
lord ainsley bowden and of course the
inseparable one
the coast young gunner on this show
so let's get a shout out man where can
the five people find you what you got
going on sir
oh man yeah so thanks guys man it's
always a blast coming on and chatting
with you
um so season gaming everywhere you can
find me on porsche power online on
everywhere um check out season gaming
podcast every saturday at noon
uh with dan who's been in the chat and
uh we have guests every week next week
really looking forward to it because
we've got kog
[Music]
xbox what a dynamic duo duo show
that's what we're gonna do so i'm
looking forward to that would be king's
first time on the big cast as well it's
been
way too long so really looking forward
to that definitely um
other than that man uh yes just check
out season game and really appreciate
you having me on as always and uh we'll
get it
absolutely and of course the incepted
one himself
the ghost we're gonna five people find
you what you got going on sir
uh yo real talk if any of you are able
to check out the xbox expansion pass on
all of your podcast services
please do so you know the grind is real
when you're making a content
solo show good show luke good show luke
fantastic thank you buddy i appreciate
it and i will i will tease
dropping uh it starts i think i drop
around 9pm tonight or whatnot
uh if you want to know some behind the
scenes what went down with mixer
and its demise you listen to tomorrow's
xcp
there's some some good info in that uh i
don't know if it's public info
so it could be something special so
check that out
i'm i'm excited for that and uh yeah um
insipid ghost on all the the twitters
and twitch and all that stuff but xbox
expansion pass man please check that out
please check it out man guy he runs a
fantastic audio podcast
one of the best the production values
are second to none
very quality very informative please
support the ghosts
check them out like i said of course
seasongaming.com those are our brothers
great news great pieces you know what i
mean high quality of course the typical
og lord addict
what a show from you today five people
find you
besides making videos and doing all the
stuff you've been doing
well you can follow me on twitter lord
addict iop
you can find me at youtube a gaming
addict i just put a video out
about um halo and you can also you know
find me cutting out these clippings of a
king running for that bend the knee
segment but you know that's beside the
point
uh definitely appreciate it i apologize
i was late uh my phone went dead and i
saw i didn't hear the alarm go off
my brother because he had no niece
i'm not
until it comes up to that oh yeah might
win that let's not do that like you're
not
you're already gone
yeah moving on sir get your
see you you keep talking king but all i
hear is running that's all i hear is
running
i don't hear no running from you cause
you i don't know
here soon i i i'm
whatever man i don't care i don't care
especially
i don't care i will describe it however
i want if i want to call this game ghost
i'm going to focus attic focus
but you know once again uh i
do appreciate everyone for coming
through there's like 400 people deep i
appreciate
tim ghost uh all the guests for coming
through
uh you know and i hope uh everyone has a
good week thank you sir appreciate it
except for listen king
you say bad stuff to me i beat your
knees i mean
it's cool man don't start them up again
at the end of the day when you keep
running from every bend in the new
segment
obviously i ain't like that if i feel
if i feel strong about my convictions
guess what king i do up in that knee
moving
you don't do that lord sovereign
interrupted as always
first off big shout out to aims to
ghosts to tim dog
for coming through and adding some
levity to them
[Laughter]
um yeah um where can you find me you can
find me on twitter
top iop once again you can't say twitter
like that it's
not that's that's a trademark thing it's
not trademark sorry
sorry i steal what i want to i'm the
iron bank thank you very much
um first of all big shout out to blaze
as well for that giveaway that's
fantastic
um the the lords as well gave away some
stuff we gave away a god of war code a
little bit early on so congratulations
whoever got that and i'm gonna have one
more for you guys
we have another playstation open world
game from this generation you might know
it
name horizon zero dawn and that is going
in the chat right now
boom for staying rocking with us grab it
get that
grab that go get that um yeah absolutely
big shout out thursday's gonna be fun
thursday gonna be a fun day um
as it turns out i have to work that day
so then i have to
rather than call in early and make
something up i have to make something up
on the fly
okay so so that'll be happening guys
some emergency will be going down
respect to the random sickness no doubt
lord king we're gonna find people
finding what you have going on sir
first i would like to say to all our
esteemed guests from tim dawg to ainsley
to the ghosts
thank you brothers for sitting here for
this four hours
you got out there lucky you let the dogs
out and hey
hold the dog's loose i gotta go
[Laughter]
about it um first i would like for you
to go to lawsongaming.net uh
right now i noticed that uh dunk lords
is
up we have a great interview that we did
while we was at pax
it's a fantastic game if you have uh
xbox
live it's free right now for free go
play that
um and you will understand why it's a
great game and i knew it was coming to
game pass
if you look at the interview he was
talking
about it and he was talking about how he
was gonna
you know do something but he couldn't
say stuff so it's gonna go to you know
to this part and then it'll make its way
to game pass um
oh what's up statue yes right there you
got miles morales you guys voted on him
he's gonna get out that box
i'm gonna unbox that i got four videos
coming this week
four videos chronicalizing uh
my views and my takes in in in what i've
seen going so far for leading us
up to the 23rd all the way up to the
date
so it's actually monday tuesday
wednesday thursday
um i'm going to drop them on twitter and
then i'll probably drop
well i can't drop them on youtube
because it's going to be monetized the
music that i will be using will
definitely be
seven days
you know the candles and stuff is
beautiful for me um but that's what
we're gonna be leading up to
and we're going to be leading up to that
day listen guys if um any of you xbox
guys are told to keep your expectations
in check kick them in the chest
don't because these sony dudes get happy
when they
mark cheney says send me your ears so i
want you guys to stand up i want you
guys to shout i want you guys to be
proud because
you don't know how close to the brink
you was before phil dominus maxim is
soon to be a really a spencer that is
true stepped in
and i think they gave him a job to fail
i think
i think he's that guy that he was like
okay y'all playing the game and he was
the rookie dude that was inside the back
he always been
with the team but he's a rookie dude
they've been in the back and everybody
else like bailed on the team
and he was like i'll take it boss and he
was like yeah man just set him out there
against all odds
and he don't die he did not die he
actually
succeeded he actually landed in pachinki
i'ma keep saying this uh this the
scenario
because i love when he got pubg he and i
think that was the
part of this that was the start of the
coup for me
he landed in a cheeky with a butter
knife and your man right now is about to
close in on that winter winter chicken
dinner he's
right there and it's just him
and it's that playstation is right above
right there he's they
both battling the circle of small and
and i got faith for my dude
get close to the fence on thursday
people will be checking for you there's
no question oh
man i'm ready for i'm ready for every
last
drop of that smoke i notice when
they have a show i get ads
i notice when they talk about a game or
when microsoft cuts off some jobs i get
ads they don't add me any other time and
i'm
up 24 hours a day regularly
smoking you dude so you can find me
on twitter at king david otw
with the full gauge smoking yes
we know with three moves
real quick up stitch 6669
attic uniform at okay it's coming shout
out
yo shout out to jonathan b excellent
intro lords now let's start the show
i'm done with you you're stupid what are
you trying to say
that king is the floyd mayweather of
betting
great show guys look you know again we
got regulated as well
they're fantastic show you lords give it
a 100 every show
oh okay cool cool so yo look man fantasy
show again thanks for watching civil law
but we had to get these balls off
tune in thursday we will do the live
reactions check us out
saturday check us out big king over
there what our brother is little caesars
gave an iron lord
connect you know what i'm saying and
then sunday we got a special treat will
be a recap show
and uh attic we got the xbox 2 coming in
for the aftermath
so stay tuned for that that should be
fun again salute my brother
except the ghost xbox expansion pass
fantastic tazowich we gonna get you
before we get out please get that
i'll beat ourselves uh sup lords and
guests king only one more box than two
hulk is complete can't wait yo everybody
enjoy your sunday thanks for rocking
with us
peace hi i'm king david of iron lords
podcast
and we're bringing to you an exciting
new giveaway
this giveaway is like none other we'll
be giving away
a xbox series x that's right
you heard me right the brand new console
launching from microsoft this year
well this is how you're able
to be part of that giveaway there's
two ways to get your name
thrown in the hat for the raffle
one become a member of the realm
that's hit that join button hit that joy
button you hit that join button down at
the bottom
and you can become a member and also
another way is by becoming a patreon
member
so you can be part of the realm as well
now this is brought to you by cat daddy
fat stacks
a member and lord of the realm
a very generous person that's in
our community and this community
is beautiful so remember
you can have one entry by hitting that
join button
and becoming a member of the realm and
also you can have another entry
by being a patreon now you said king
what if i'm a member of both well your
name gets thrown in the hat
two times so please
like follow and subscribe
join or become a patreon member
or become both and your name
is in the hat to get that
xbox series x
that's the who did that for you
sweepstakes
this is wonderful this is something that
i'm sure that you will enjoy
oh man